a May 15th
we're here again
[Applause]
[Music]
uh happy Monday to everybody
it is Wednesday
I'm having a case of the Mondays over
here what about you guys anyone having a
case for the Mondays
every day
Monday every day Zach is back in the
studio yeah
who just sold Up played a sold out show
at the Roxbury
sure did
I saw some funny posts on the subred
about people like uh where's everybody
on Sunday yeah people were showing up to
the wrong venue people were showing up
on the wrong date they're like I've been
in line for 24 hours no one's here yeah
I don't know why they're so confused I
don't get it man I don't get it
um my brother went to your show did you
know that I heard yeah he went with uh
Jeremiah yeah yeah
by the way today's episode is sponsored
by stamps.com thank you we love them so
much and our members
we love so much your brother was there
yeah okay uh one sec and then by the way
remember yeah he was what and then and
then um
members will see that we put up an
exclusive
full crew reaction uh to the Zach lore
video part one it's like 40 minutes long
but it's good
check it out members
yes so um
Zach's big day was on uh Saturday yes
and my brother you know is friends with
Karen and Jeremiah they moved here
that's how we met them
I didn't know that yes so oh my brother
used to live in Vegas yeah yeah his wife
via her best friend is Karen
I had no idea Karen came to visit
and then we were looking for an HR
person right and uh so Ela and Karen
started talking and then
uh anyway they worked out so she moved
here with her husband Jeremiah
so then Jeremiah gets invited to Zach's
show
right and my brother is friends with
Jeremiah and he goes with Jeremiah Zach
show well Jericho Jeremiah was cool he
he bought a ticket I'm like why did you
why did you buy a ticket I would have
added you you know he's a good man no
he's a great [__] guy
um and um he's like can I get a plus one
I'm like yeah absolutely
um for my brother he didn't even mention
no no because I you know I thought it
was for Karen or something but um no I'm
glad I'm glad your brother came out that
was cool
yeah say hi to any of us my brother
who's there he's a strange duck
I'll be honest Zach my brother hated it
oh did he not because of you but someone
kept blowing Vape smoke in his eye I saw
that [__] he was like right right in
the front yeah so so my brother he came
over our house yesterday we have all the
family comes over on Sunday and his his
right eye is [__] oh no I was like bro
what happened to you it looks like he
has mad pink eye or something wait from
from Vape smoking apparently something
happened at the show
that [__] his eye up and and his
stairs that someone was blowing Vape
smoke in his eye there there was a dude
blowing Vape there was also a dude that
was puffing on a doobie the whole show
um that's a good vibe right or no yeah
yeah weed smokers welcome you know
that's at every live show yeah yeah um
but I don't know how would that have
caused the my brother he's not
he you know it's like Jurassic Park life
finds a way
but he thought the music was great
well at least you didn't have to see you
know you could just hear it yeah but
yeah exactly there you go exactly but uh
I thought that was really funny yeah
I was like what happened to you bro he's
like I went to Zach's show I was like
wait what
come get a pink eye Zach Lewis concert
so uh what do you you all went right how
was the show Zach how was the show it
was absolutely amazing nice I want to
thank everyone for coming out
um it was very surreal experience there
was some issue with people at the venue
but what tell me I want the gosh
um they weren't letting people in we
almost didn't get it yeah everyone oh
you guys almost didn't get it yeah well
that's um interesting they were on the
priority guest list
um
the venue kept [__] up with the guest
lift guest list for some reason
um I had was standing out there arguing
with the guy they weren't gonna let my
uncle in what the [__] I the guy's like
if you wanna you wanna go play somewhere
else go play in your backyard I'm like
are you [__] serious right now wait
hold on hold on hold on hold on what he
said who will go play in their backyard
me to me he said you go play in your
bathroom like if you want to go play
somewhere that's bigger go play in your
backyard I'm like are you [__]
serious I'm like they're getting so much
money from the [__] bar
like that's my name up on the Marquee
are you [__] serious you're not gonna
let any of these no respects no respect
well what happened why was there was it
crowded was it packed oversold kind of
sort of yeah how did how do you oversell
a venue I don't understand that
everyone remember for the last month
when Zach was like just a few tickets
left at the Roxy just a few seconds left
get your tickets okay but well
apparently but how do you but they have
a finite amount of tickets right so how
do they oversell them I I don't know
specifically why they weren't letting
people in especially on the guest list
that were family crew friends like
priority people so you got so you guys I
got in eventually it was nice yeah but
it was like really we got in after like
10 minutes maybe five minutes it was but
with my uncle they my dad was out there
arguing with them they weren't gonna let
my bass player's parents in they almost
threw my dad out so was the guest list
too extensive perhaps it was a combo of
my people other bands people because
there were three acts total yeah I heard
you have two opening shows dude I was
like what okay
um yeah
um but my guy David got everyone in I
gotta give a shout out to him I don't
know how he did it I don't know how he
got around him but how many people are
in your guys's guest list there was a
total of like 80 people
well of course no baby but he's cool
wait hold the [__] on how many how
that's like a fifth of the whole event
well here's the thing though we set
aside a certain amount of tickets and
there was 25 tickets we put aside that's
a lot less than 80. this is gonna happen
so we went to eat first me and the rest
of Christmas wait hold on no wonder
they're like yo [__] you guys you're not
it doesn't matter though yes it does you
can't do you you can't it's there it's
not Doctor Who's a [__] telephone box
I mean there's like fire code and [__]
[__] it sorry if you go ahead no it's
fine I was just saying we went to go eat
first we all went to Saddle Ranch and
then we went there after and so everyone
else was kind of inside already so
outside was just us the crew and Gabe
and his nephew standing there and all
the fans were already inside they were
kind of like peeking outside as we were
trying to get it's so funny yeah Zach
that is so [__] funny I felt bad for
Zach though because like he had to come
out and sort things out five minutes
before he's supposed to hit the stage so
he's all stressed out but thank you very
much for getting us inside yeah it all
worked out at all it was fine I did that
was so funny bro I was like it's
probably good it happened to us and not
people that bought tickets and then
weren't able to well they probably yeah
they probably letting people bought
tickets and everyone's like yeah I'm on
the guests are like yeah you and
everybody else [__] off I'm too nice man
I'm sorry you know like I it's like 80
dude that is funny but it wasn't it
wasn't just 80 people of mine I know but
like I know I know I know that's awesome
that is the best thing ever but it all
got worked out and it got accommodated
so you've sold a packed ass
[__] show oversold [__] show
you know supposedly that's inspiring man
there was a Family Guy scammed about a
fake ticket yeah I felt so bad for that
guy did he get in no he didn't get in
how do you buy fit how did that happen I
guess got it from Reddit or something oh
this is him yeah I saw the title but I
didn't understand like he was the you
took a photo with him yeah because I was
standing out there trying to deal with
whatever the [__] was going on
um and they're like oh they're not
taking my tickets and then my guy David
is like no those are those are ticket
web tickets those should work but I
guess they were can we hook him up with
some like Live show tickets
guys if you want to get on our guest
list for the live show just email Dan
I'm gonna put everybody shut the [__] up
don't say that that's not real you're
not getting on well hold on hold on hold
on there's a hundred there's 1500
tickets to our live show and according
to Zach's math we can do about um like a
fifth of that a fit yeah a fifth so
that's like that's at least like three
350 people
the guest list wasn't just friends and
family there were also people that had
issues with tickets that had messaged me
previously
long stories it wasn't just friends and
family
so it's funny man it's best so anyway it
sounds like y'all had a great night yeah
it was yeah it was fun it was fun
congrats Zach thank you really the
funniest thing that happened to me all
night is right as we walked up
the first dude he's like yo what's up
Dan he wasn't there for the show he
wasn't there for the show he just was
walking down the street right as we
walked up and then he like saw all of us
and he's like what the [__] going know
are you all here we're like we're at
Zach's show aren't you he's like no
that's funny I love that
but
um circling bag everything got resolved
they came up to apologize to me at the
end okay good
um so everything's coaching that's nice
Yeah Yeah well considering that it's
pretty incredible that they accommodated
all that yeah Zach something cool
happened to me on Saturday before your
show about your show oh I was in a
parking garage and a girl noticed me in
my car and she put her window down and
she was like I'm going to Zach's show
tonight oh my God that's amazing see you
there
that's awesome I still haven't been to
the cattle Saddle Ranch
it was a cattle ranch whatever you like
it Ava you said oh yeah it was really
good yeah I got prime rib oh hell yeah
brother Sam's nodding yes to Saddle
Ranch they have truly one of the best
steaks I've ever had are you serious
right now it's really good I was sipping
I still want to do our Dave and Buster's
Saddle Ranch yo you know what so you
know what's next to Saddle Ranch is
dobricks right and that [__] was [__]
popping I gotta say there was so many
people they're still eating that [__]
yeah gotta gotta say David's crushing it
in the pizza game
wow
I was surprised I was surprised how busy
it was
the pizza looks good
I guess I don't know
it's okay I mean you wouldn't go there
unless you were a fan of his right
why would you go eat there if you
weren't it's a great location I don't
think I don't think that's true at all
really it's right next to all the clubs
and stuff okay dobrics yeah
with each uh purchase of pizza you get a
free a QR code to enter you to win a
million dollars
[Music]
so but like for real though
we should
you guys want to do like uh we should do
a Dave and Buster's Saddle Ranch party
so my this week my drummer works at Dave
and Buster's
um and he we got the hook up there with
some [__] what's the hook up at Dave and
Buster's I don't know I'll pay for stuff
I don't think it's that expensive I'll
pay for it you know uh what do you mean
by Dave and Buster's Saddle Ranch are
they are they not close or do we just go
to Dave and Buster's yeah no they're not
anywhere close together they're not same
city they're both in Los Angeles it's
probably like a 10 minute Uber don't you
think that'd be fun to do that and then
go or should we just 100 do both should
we just what do you think's better just
all Dave and Busters I think all Dave
and Busters because their wings are
crazy okay I would rather eat at Dave
and Buster's in Saddle Ranch TBH
okay so people are saying people are
saying 620 000 at Dave and Busters
dude we could get so many [__] let's
do that this week you guys we have so
many prize tickets
I'll make the reservation right now I
just gotta I'm gonna message you let's
find one's the best night to do it
I've been wanting to do that with you
guys
nice
I'm I'm just texting here play some Zach
let your connect now we're coming
through let him know bro be ready you
got it get that it would be nice if we
could probably have a room like a party
room or something just so we could have
a little or do we need that when we're
eating
I'm gonna be [__] gaming so hard dude
I'm not gonna you'll be eating at the
games yeah a beer tube
right
got like beard like the hats with the
crazy straws that come down I want to go
tonight
I'll go right now I didn't want to win
the [__] show I'm ready to go [__]
the podcast let's go to DM it's been
real thanks for watching what's the what
kind of games do you like there because
it's all kind of like I'm just I'm being
over the top I don't know it's just like
normal arcade games right DDR I mean are
you there for this video are you there
to win tickets are you there to shoot
demons you know what I mean I guess you
gotta all the above dude I'm bringing my
switch if we go I'm be honest I'll eat
the wings and I'll just sit there and
play my switch there's this basketball
game that I could spend the whole night
playing okay that's what I like to hear
I want to go it's Connect Four with
basketballs Dave and Buster's basketball
yo I'm gonna have to get a lot of
quarters
I'm gonna cover wait is it pretty sure
it's the card system yeah I'm pretty
sure we're past the days of the quarter
it's been a while yeah I guess I'm
getting old
uh
it's a different one Connect Four
oh no it's not that one normal uh is it
a multiplayer game
um yes yes Connect Four enough to two
people
that looks I don't know what it's called
on the left is that just a slot machine
oh it looks kind of like that second
picture
maybe oh oh okay I think it's that okay
yeah yeah yeah that's what it is love
that okay we're in but those aren't
full-size basketballs are they they're
like little
I think they're full size oh it is okay
I guess it's a weird it's not tiny this
looks like a tiny little thing but I
guess maybe it's full size you should
try to reach out to this guy though
we'll put him on our guest list for
for uh the live show
you know what I mean
and then a lot of other people
yeah everybody we have we have some I
don't understand the issue with that bro
you can't add an unlimited amount of
people
80. that wasn't fully me though how many
did you add I know but I don't know the
exact count but it was you guys were
family there's one friends there's one
guest list Zach
hey it's your show right
I'm just wondering if you put on there
because that that
that makes a difference but it doesn't
really because it's Zach's show there's
one guest list
so it's a finite space right
so Zach should have told like the
openers that they can't put people on
the guest list is that what you're
saying well there needs to be I don't
know what I don't know the the politics
of it but there needs to be some
communication I'm surprised the venue
itself didn't say this is the amount of
yes spots we're giving you right that's
that's how it usually goes dude most
people don't even have that many people
at their wedding
yeah but we got in so it doesn't I'm
just kid do you not you don't
do not understand where I'm coming from
at all no I can see your point of view
okay yeah
it's awesome though so fun
I don't know 80 people right I don't I
don't know
but it's very nice cliff diver King says
thanks to Zach for having me on the list
you had fun cliff diver King who else
was on Zach's guest list out there in
the audience
you know there were also people like I
said that message me saying that they
might have had trouble with their
tickets or whatever it may be we looked
into it and we just we just comped them
sorry Fuego says I had so much fun
thanks Zach for putting me on the guest
list
nice
so people who paid for VIPs that could
be in that section right with us okay
yeah
my parents were there they were on
Zach's guest list
Don Gary yeah they were there yesterday
said hi Kevin you [__] I didn't have to
read this to know you're full of [__]
Ethan it's your Nemesis I'll take a spot
on the guest list
[Laughter]
dumbass not sure about that one Kevin
maybe Zach's guest list
when we got there we got there at the
same time as Gabe and Nick Nick and Gabe
was on the list but Nick Nick got the
nope
not you uh but he got in eventually too
all right well that's nice they they
accommodated dude Zach's brother trying
to pull the robbery on Lena got Lena
inside and then I could not find her
anywhere
just damn you guys excuse to use the
bathroom
and then did he run off with your wife
no she had to use the bathroom and then
uh he got her in just for that but then
Zach's dad's like oh Lena he's a big fan
of you can I get a picture of you guys
together oh come on his family effort
right now
that is such a weirdo okay but I guess
should I explain the context of that
I think we have before that that your
your brother
I don't know how to say it he likes her
that makes it sound like he's like a
child but I guess but he likes her right
he thinks you want to express on her a
little bit but he's very respectful nice
guy we love Jared
a beautiful lady so Todd the Todd and
Tuck Zach's dad
he goes and this this is funny because
I've met Todd
so he Corners Lena and Zach's brother
and says yo he loves you let's take a
photo together
I I want to say cornered but
[Music]
Zack's status respectfully such a
character no but he's Todd's a man he
came out and he was trying to get us all
in whenever we were locked and Frank
kept coming out and like fighting with
all the security trying to get everybody
inside
that sounds like quite a night
it was fun yeah it was very fun anyone
else get pink eye
no no okay
only one case of uh Pink guy I tried I
tried
congrats Zach thank you I just it was an
exceptional night and um
it was it was just unreal just [__]
unreal uh Carol Robb says I was at
Zach's show it was my birthday I made
you all sign a hundred dollar bill P.S
thanks for getting me on the guest list
uh she didn't say that uh I I remember
that I remember thinking like aren't you
a hundred dollars is like a lot yeah
like you're gonna want that you're gonna
want that was that a real hundred dollar
bill yeah that's I mean that's a cry I
assume so it's a crime yeah Carol you've
been reported FBI yeah
although you guys are complicit I would
never do such thing right right you only
abide by all laws yes yeah that's right
Zach Zach's manager was telling me that
Zach is the first artist to sell out all
three of those venues and like I forget
how long it was do you know that it was
like a little little over a year it was
about a year and a half yeah yeah it's
awesome
that's great yeah but I'm what the what
a guy man hmm Zach Zach Lewis live thank
you yes it was it was awesome
so uh moving on a little bit here
um
I do want to say briefly here
this is my
this is my baby this is my uh uh
I guess we don't have more pictures
maybe we can get more pictures Sam
you want more yeah I don't know if
there's any likes of these Lifestyles I
could show I can put a gallery together
that'd be great
this is our Classic this is our Classics
Collection okay
now there's a whole story here okay you
want Amy's wearing it too looking really
good
I didn't realize we were doing this I
got one as well
it's black
um
you're not gonna be able to see it but
yeah so here's the here's the story
so when the when inflation started
hitting and post covid and the price the
prices of everything was going crazy
inflation shipping the price of cotton
went up like 10 times
and
you know it was obvious that
as we were forced to raise our prices
that it was becoming more and more
difficult for people to afford to buy
our stuff
and so
we had this idea
what if we instead of raising our prices
as our cost of goods is increasing
that we lower our prices
to create an opportunity
for our audience and anyone else who
wants to wear great stuff to be able to
afford this stuff in in the climate
where the prices are going up so much
and so started this project
where we sourced we started with the
best the nicest fleece that we use
and we parried it down to its most basic
form
it's lightweight it's it's beautiful
it's cozy it's comfy it's got one patch
it's simple as possible
and then
once we got the price down as much as
possible then we took it a step further
and just ate in way into our margin
to bring about an affordable
super high quality collection
you know what I mean that so that
everybody can still consume what in my
opinion is a luxury luxury goods here
and the prices are going to blow you
guys away I hope
I hope
we're gonna pay you to take this offer
you're on my guest list thirty dollars a
piece we're gonna pay you thirty dollars
to wear this it's not quite that good oh
no but people in the company they says
it's you're not gonna be able to get it
down to that much price
they said you can't do it it's it's mad
it's just alone I'm not even kidding
they told me that
and I said Dan you think I'm kidding
I just can't believe it people the our
head of finances that's not a reasonable
that's not realistic goal have the
owners lost their minds so actually I
don't I don't want to misspeak on the
prices but I think for example and what
Amy when you saw it on the rack what did
you say I said I'm sorry but I want one
of every single one of these you well
when I told you the theory on our
collection you said I thought these were
more expensive yeah I thought they were
more expensive yeah dab me up brother
reminds me I'd be like uh Essentials uh
fear of God but honestly quality seems a
little better if I'm being honest it is
it is better the quality is stunning and
so this is coming out on Thursday right
Sam
the 18th the 18th that's yeah Thursday
or the or the hoodies with the little
barriers that yeah we have a whole line
okay I was wearing that the other day
too okay asking about it so we've got
like the crew neck the hoodie the Zips
the bare ears super cozy and long uh
long uh pants I'm about to drop the
gallery oh thank you so much so I'm very
excited about this you know I I
it's a passion project
and I I think it's um
this is like a line that's going to
hopefully live on our website where
everybody can uh
enjoy it and partake in it we're going
to be continuing doing our normal
Collections and stuff are you not
allowed to save the price yet no I just
don't want to misspeak oh I don't
remember the exact price because we it
was always moving around a little bit as
we're kind of trying to to get as low as
possible the line I know some of the
pricing and it's very fair how much is
this crew neck I don't know I don't know
specifics I know kind of like a range
but I think for example I think the
women's tee is like 20 bucks that that's
it I think is 50 bucks or 55 I don't
remember which
you don't think so I think it's
I'm just saying I'm not sure I think
it's 50 to 50 but 50 to 55 bucks for the
crew neck
so yeah and we're selling shirts for
20 or 25 anyway well we'll see we'll see
like I said I don't I don't want to
misspeak I dropped a link right under
thank you
so I'm very excited about this
uh check it out the colors are really
awesome earthy tones I love this purple
the hats we've got a hat in the
collection everything you guys are going
to be stunned by the prices here shorts
I'm so excited I saw excited
oh this is all unisex coming out
tomorrow then we have women specific
stuff coming out
shortly after
but this is all unisex so we are women
We Are Men
[Music]
so uh socks socks are included so I'm
super I'm super pumped oh yeah thick
thank you that's it yeah thank you guys
mm-hmm
thank you thank you so much
[Applause]
thank you thank you people yeah I knew
you guys would like the uh the bare ears
love it hell yes there there are some
hoodies without the ears though right
yeah there's a zip for both exactly
exactly Russell the bear
nice to have you back on the soundboard
Zach we had fun in your absence but
we are we connect on a spiritual level
you bring us absolutely bring a certain
X Factor
yes I mean that's what I wanted to say
but I Genesis how can you say that
correctly but like anything else
[Music]
well don't you know it's because of
Babel oh right oh yes
Ian was tutoring it's good to be back
yeah
um
it drops on Thursday guys
people are asking if it's that Urban I
don't no it's not going to be because
it's the margin's crazy like if we sold
it to Urban
we'd probably lose money where's your
cut we would def we would lose we would
be paying you
yeah exactly but anyway I'm very excited
so thank you guys
um
you guys seen about the title obviously
my marriage I have a big update about my
marriage things have been obviously as a
lot of people have noted
uh
[Music]
people have noted that I'm sleeping in a
different room
yeah Daniela
people have noticed that she's posting
uh she's actually been exercising
has been tense when she comes on on
Fridays it's been tense in this room
and
you know she's been posting pictures
where you can see a tiny bit of cleavage
so obviously the signs of a
she's joining only fans
[Music]
so the signs of a real estate agent
keeps coming by
the Milkman yeah I don't even we don't
order milk it's weird get it from the
grocery store
tennis instructor
uh what was that uh quote again
don't say it it's too painful oh no no
coconuts are divorced oh come on oh my
God give the man a break
so now that I'm up you're down
it's too painful please coconuts have a
heart
in fact as you can see I'm already
getting owned on Twitter you're so owned
because on Friday we announced Ela
starting her only fans ugh Bobby
[__]
Bobby caught us actually I want to look
through the the comments here
damn he caught a slip and with that
title and thumbnail of our show
well this is why I'm watching as you can
see um
the comments are crazy under that one
dude
I uh a lot of people just
oh here here check out this comment you
know and this hurts me a lot I'm not
surprised though I do feel bad for the
kid if things get X-rated
because when they grow up it's
definitely going to get awkward though
she is gorgeous so I'll be watching
legally
first person to ever admit that they
find her attractive and that to me is a
problem
that makes me feel very insecure right
you know
it's been tough
you are down
[Laughter]
somebody said boby's now here oh here he
is look Bobby
left a comment
I didn't fall for the bait I checked the
video to see if it was true and it
wasn't but I still wanted to post the
title thumbnail on my Twitter so I just
made the caption question question
because I didn't want to say it was true
but I also wanted to see people fall for
the clickbait on Twitter
somebody probably he was he was double
trolling dude summoned our Troll and
took it even further bro bro before he
came this user literally predicted and
before Bobby comes here and comments it
was 40 to death and just a troll and
then this guy says damn you called it
damn bow be careful in the subreddit
because you people were enjoying you but
this one's got minus 200. don't push
Bobby is uh coming to town soon he asked
if I wanted to hang out maybe uh maybe
come to Dave and Buster's with us we put
him on the guest list
the Dave and Busters
but I have 200 people so I can't
guarantee he'll get it oh [__] I feel
like Bobby would be randomly really good
at DDR I agree like you would have like
crazy DDR skills Ali versus bobi yeah
yeah yeah yeah okay guys please enter
the century being serious okay I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry
that's a matter
go ahead keep playing that doesn't
matter
is this about this is an adobe original
Style
with your trans if you're what killed
if you're anything but black kill
yourself cause black lives matter
black lives of matter
uh
cap nice thank you says delete it please
there's a lot of people asking delete it
please several people asking please
delete it we beg you there are people
feeling sick seeing this there are
people crying delete it please delete it
please people are feeling sick with the
that was a reference I believe yeah yes
it's a copy pasta first big news big
news
so anyway as people have suspected there
is trouble in Paradise and
I have two young boys and I don't want
to I just want the best outcome for them
which is why yesterday was Mother's Day
oh that had to have been so hard oh my
it's Mommy makeout day
and we um I knew what it was sorry I'm
so sorry that was inappropriate
with him I don't know the real estate
agent the Milkman no whoever
what are you saying about her you think
the whole [__] Block's coming over
and making out with Ayla the Milkman the
agent the Mother's Day The Gardener the
pool guy
hey Dan
you but I mean the AC guy
the AC guy
and Iola is a Greek goddess the garbage
man
the 80 people is that kind of this VIP
list
okay guys be respectful
[Music]
um so Sunday was Mother's Day
we had the whole family over
we got
um
we bought uh some really tasty uh
Israeli food we catered it
this place called me it was having some
tasty of Israeli food as well
hmm
the the Israelis yeah no she did enjoy
it she did enjoy the food right yeah
it was very good that's what I said
I'm so sorry this is this is serious
bro come on man's exact show changed in
Dan what the [__] bro come on
it's not your fault hey I know you you
better you get better get ready to start
producing for fresh and Fit I doubt they
pay as good by the way
they probably don't pay at all
[__]
okay can I so anyway we got great
Israeli food
the place called habaite shout out
they're really good I recommend it means
the home in in Hebrew
[Music]
and then after the meal
I told Ela that uh we're
gonna go to Italy together
trip to save the marriage
you know
she always wanted to go to Italy we're
going we're going to go to uh
Florence
you're going to Sicily
a little Sicily
[Music]
to get in touch with your roots he has
no pizza experience or Leone I'm going
to uh why so that the [__] uh
so that the cow milker can [__] my wife
Dan
I don't know
the vineyard people so the wine people
people
too much wine sorry
so anyway that's basically uh the update
regarding my marriage
yeah
that's it it's heavy
so uh we'll see
we'll see what how I love to see how
they spin this title and thumbnail
Ethan is getting a divorce
oh and everything and you know I'm
getting ready to practice my accent out
there I love you
foreign
I love your pizza
what is the secrets Giacomo
Giacomo he has no pizza experience
Pinocchio I love it a pizza
[Music]
you gonna be going to Rome no
we don't have a ton of time because of
[Music]
we're actually going to bring the kids
so it's gonna be
it's going to be kind of crazy
kids loved Hitler
um wait can I
well no
wait why can I say that
I can say that right yeah
well where is Vatican City it's near
Rome it's in Rome yeah I'm not allowed
near there
so we're going to Florence gotcha
uh the kids are coming and so it's gonna
be great I'm really excited and
hey
Japan though
I love you that sounds great
though I you got this Pizzeria
where do you get that mozzarella I love
it
[Laughter]
where's the Mario brothers from
I want you to visit the historical site
you know whether the famous Plumbing
Brothers where is it they're from
you're gonna love this
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh
he's so cool
I'm looking at popular Italian names
because I ran out
Antonio
I have a cousin named jacobo
what is it yakapo yeah
I love you
Giovanni Giovanni
tell me what what it is I can buy a
little Pastoria
foreign
[Music]
Tony well that's like an American one
I'm looking for like real ass Italian
names like uh
Giuseppe
[Music]
I know it was you Fredo I know some
Italian Lena studied in Italy for a
month oh really Benito
[Music]
around here
the cappuccino
oh
Bennett Benito and Giacomo
where is uh
what is Beatrice Beatrice Luigi yo
Luigi's on here top Italian names Luigi
yo that's [__] sick there's people
named Luigi
did you not know his real name well I
figured I've met a few Luigi's in my
life oh you have yeah I never met one I
figure it was just like once it became a
meme people phased out I guess that
might be true Luigi
Lorenzo
all right let's thank our sponsors and
then uh
we got a whole great show here for you
guys actually
and you guys might notice I feel like
skinny today I see lots of comments
about it
[Music]
one of these Fitness guys apparently
made a video uh commending me on my
weight loss Journey
and the comments are insane
and this is from two months ago so
imagine how much respect he is for me
now
but let us thank our gracious and lovely
sponsors stamps.com just one sponsor
here today
I love I love you
episode.com
I love me stamps.com if you use the mail
if you've got a small business
or if you're a prolific mailer at that
or big business
sams.com is going to get you through
whatever it is better
then however you're doing it now
you know what I mean they've been in
business for 25 years and there's a
reason they've been in business so long
they're in the business of saving time
and money
so you can focus on your business
knowing that samsung.com has all your
posts and he's covered with premium
discounts and great rates listen to this
let me start from here
stamps.com gets you 84 off USPS and UPS
rates whoa
you know why because they have
they have so many customers over a
million businesses work with them
they're able to negotiate these massive
uh shipping costs down
so right there boom you know what I mean
then
the ease of it is incredible all you
need is a computer and a printer they
send you a free scale
so all you do is weigh this weight on
the scale print the postage put it on
your package
then you either put in a Dropbox or you
can even they'll even come get it from
your home dude I don't have to think
about it dude
thank you Crowder that sound bite is
paying dividends man
foreign
it's such a no-brainer service I
absolutely adore them they're fantastic
sponsor and I just love stamps.com so
much uh here check this out set your
business up for Success when you get
started with stamps.com today sign up at
stamps.com h3tv for a special offer that
includes a four week trial free postage
what and a free digital scale there's no
long-term commitments or contracts all
you got to do is go to stamps.com
h3tv
and uh start using it man I love it and
I love them and thank you to Samsung for
being a great uh supporter of ours
please consider supporting them thank
you
I love that the stamp is another gum
all right let's see I got all kinds of
so let's watch this Fitness Guy this is
from two months ago so I guess I I
probably had done
my first push at Weight Loss
uh but then I guess I'm in my second
push now wait real quick before we move
on I just
could you get this to ELO this was
accidentally sent here I think this was
a Mother's Day card why would that go
down meant to be
well it's from uh
I don't think he meant that for ELO
you don't think so
what he can't see it
yeah that looks good uh that looks about
right
okay there's something that that is it
that's the monitor
there appears to be some technical issue
happening
interesting I'm terrible technical
issues
you don't have to keep it on
can they see the meme or what I guess
not I don't understand because you are
showing my screen when you pull that up
all right well you guys know what it is
just Dan being Dan making jokes about
my
innocent wife
or should I move on
yeah so here's the video this wait hold
on this guy made a 55 second video
y'all know this is how easy it is to get
views with my [__] name in these
circles 55 seconds who watches a 55
second video it has 350 000 views
this has got to be one of his top viewed
videos right watch this [__]
let's see
oh it's not even close Okay arrogant
well it's only two months old give it
time but it is one of his more recent
bangers I would say yeah let's see
latest
fifty thousand seven oh okay 80 180.
wait what they're all under a minute
what kind of content are you making
brother
all right so let's watch it
a few months ago Ethan Klein was getting
a lot of attention for his interesting
opinions on exercise okay [__]
don't be saying I said this [__]
support the exercise I'm just gonna be
honest there's I'm a comedian and people
are laughing
many better things to do than exercise
it sucks being fat I just want to be
here
a lot of it's better since I've lost
like 20 30 pounds bro so bro watch this
podcast about me explaining how that
whole thing was so silly and stupid
and then he's just like
whatever it was hard for me to trim my
toenails losing 30 pounds is an insane
achievement so it deserves credit where
it's due because so many people
including myself clowned in before but
oh you clown me [__]
dumbass for what being fat
like it's just like I get I like that
he's trying to like be supportive that's
cool but dude you're you're criticizing
me for being fat fat fat fat fat fat fat
fat
and watch now as I lose weight and then
all these people magically start having
respect for me again it's [__] crazy
it's sad it's like he's fat but he's one
of the good ones he's one of the good
fatties
a righteous a righteous obese boy like a
John Candy type you know one of the good
ones uh he was the best these guys they
literally think that
Jim
they think insulting the gym is like
drawing Muhammad it's it's like they
they it's not a personal attack on you
bro
and also I was kidding like come on
somebody please admit that there wasn't
serious point in the beginning
nobody wants to touch that come on man
this man thinks the gym is Mecca dude
it's not that serious
one video about this new opinion and on
his weight loss the thing that made can
you pull up his video of me criticizing
me I gotta see that one Jim decided to
change was for the most noble reason you
can think of and also I don't want to
die I've got two boys and I want to live
a long time for them and beat him to
share my life with them and I think this
is the perfect example of how far you
can get if you look for reasons to keep
going instead of reasons to quit thank
you so much for watching subscribe okay
dude
I appreciate the support though it's
nice he's it's nice to see right this is
it this is good
I'm not trying to go too hard on on the
boy here who's being an ally but
this is nice I gained weight because of
medicine I was on it wasn't because I
didn't care about my boys
I found another video he made about you
but it's only a minute long as well
they're all a minute long I this man's
this man's career on YouTube is a total
a mystery to me
being fat makes me miserable it makes me
miserable being fat because I'm so fat I
can't breathe when I tie my shoes they
got me the worst part about being fat
for me is the thigh rubbing Life's too
short to exercise I'm just gonna be
honest if daily activity god dude it's
crazy they can't let that [__] joke
go
these are becoming a physical struggle
and you hate your physical health I
would highly suggest that you try to
change it rather if you're if you don't
like being fat I suggest you go for a
walk dummy
like what the [__] is your content dude
this man doesn't like being a fat so I
recommend to go for a walk and eat less
thank you for watching
one thing that I learned through my uh
journey of becoming obese
is just like how out of control it is
and how hard it is to change and how
complex that this notion of
you know
weight is
these guys cannot [__] come to face
the terms that people don't choose to be
fat
you know what I mean like homie's
probably shooting up testosterone every
goddamn day and then lecturing people on
like go for a walk fatty but again just
because our vice is visible to everybody
lets you feel Superior just because
you're not fat it's like the one thing
you have control over in your life
because you love going to the gym that's
your hobby for whatever reason that it
it makes them feel so Superior
it's a pathetic dude I hate this gym
culture it's so out of control man
I love them though at the same time also
they're my faves I'm undoing all my hard
work
other than making up excuses such as
healthy bodies don't live longer than
unhealthy boys I didn't nobody [__]
said that I didn't say that
who you arguing with dude what people
don't consider to say exercising ads on
life that's why oh my God bro
this is crazy I didn't say that but it
actually takes off three years of
productivity that's a [__] joke
but it will suck way less than getting
exhausted from tying your shoes I'm so
fat I can't breathe when I tie my shoes
it makes me miserable being fat
wait what wait what was that clip he
showed that's real struggle Ethan
wait wait wait wait wait wait hold the
phone
what the [__]
look at this poor Indian man running for
his life
this is a real struggle
he's a Giacomo now
I love this Indian man
it is a real struggle here feeling
I can't breathe what do you know about
this man what do you mean he's this is a
real struggle
that's weird
it makes me miss a very weird bat I'm
not trying why is that why is this the
epitome of struggle for you an Indian
man jogging that has to be very racist
and let's be real this dude definitely
struggles less putting on his shoes like
it's not even really makes sense oh does
he have a he has a fake leg is that
what's going on oh does he
and then well I mean oh no he doesn't oh
so this doesn't make any sense but from
tying your shoes I'm so fat no he's fine
wait is he fine oh yeah no he's fine
yeah he's good he's totally normal I'm
fine
look at this man he's struggling
he lives in India my God
is what he's saying not me
I don't I'm trying to guess what's the
struggle I don't know it makes me
miserable being fat I'm not trying to
factor him anyone but I want all of my
subscribers to be able to see their kids
grow up go on walks with their dogs and
take care of their parents I don't even
do a fat shame anyone but there's a fat
man here he says that exercising is
[__] stupid
this fat idiot I [__] hate him
but I respect this Indian man jogging
look at this Indian man jog I'm so fat
again look at it it makes me miserable
being fat I'm not trying to fatter him
what the [__] dude why is people watch
this this is so confusing half a million
views he's got half a million views 50
seconds
what is happening here wait wait what is
happening here
how is this
content appealing
damn dude someone in the comments says
as someone who has been obese my entire
life we need to start fat shaming
you said that in the comments someone
said that in the comments yeah
okay then that person is not obese yeah
I don't believe you yeah 336 likes
we need to I think there's plenty of fat
shaming bro oh wait wait in this
comments yeah yeah okay I thought you
were saying in our chat I was like what
the [__] no no no yeah because there
this is a real phenomenon of like
fat kids
they lose a bunch of weight and then
become like gym rats and then they go I
was able to lose weight because I got
bullied fat shaming is good
it's like okay
Ethan
look at this Indian man running I can't
breathe when I tie my shoes it makes me
miserable being fat I'm not trying to I
would love to pick his brain about why
he chose this
or being fat I'm not trying to Fat to
him
to be able to see their kids grow up go
on walks with their dogs and take care
of their parents and most importantly
have a nice day okay well that's the
most important as long as that's the
most important thing
have a nice day
dumbass I you lost three years of
productivity proceeds to waste time and
ruin his health instead of being
productive okay you wanna you I don't
know much about you but you want to
argue productivity bro come on
stop it
being skinny isn't the only productivity
I'm out here doing five shows a week
that's right you know what I mean like
come on call me fat but not unproductive
this channel is so weird I kind of
wanted to come and be like yo thanks for
the big ups dude which I should in a
sense I do
but the comments are not
a wise man learns from the mistakes of
others
how is that applicable to me
whose mistakes am I learning from fat
people other fat people I don't like
Ethan but I can respect him for changing
his life and trying to be healthy thank
you
the classic uh
nobody makes it at the top one
this okay so I this is a condemnation of
this whole gym culture nobody makes
better Fitness edit motivational videos
than this guy truly the best
this cream of the crop the running
Indian guy
no offense you know
I wish Ethan the best it's never too
late to make the right choices okay
thank you bro literally contradicts
himself but that's yeah because it was a
joke right
I wish you the best I'm starting to
think that these gym guys are not the
brightest
and I don't want to Bright with like a
broad brush you know but
they're just not the brightest Ethan is
the oldest looking 35 year old I've ever
seen he could easily pass his 50 plus
come on
that can't be true can it
50 plus you guys
[__] no
the strength of a oh this is great thank
you so much we know your real name we
know you're 42. kill you got eight years
42.
read into this for me the strength of a
person lies in his ability forgive this
man is he's being forced to forgive me
for my comments the strength
[Music]
the strength of a person dies
he's forgiving me his strength he's
strong because he's forgiving me for
making a joke about the gym that guy's
badass
strength of a man
yeah
it is a I'm glad to see him redeem
himself again just because I lost weight
that's all it took to redeem myself
don't you see how [__] up this world
is that quote you're about to say was in
the comments of the other video as well
I had like 50 up redeeming himself by
losing weight do you see how [__]
crazy that is
look I get I think he still doesn't like
this gym stigma but the fact that he's
willing to do this for his kids is
amazing that I appreciate that comment
because you you acknowledge I just don't
like the Gen you know I mean
honestly he was making an offhand sell
oh whoa whoa hold the [__] phone what
what what we're making an offense
self-deprecating joke that unfortunately
stayed at internet means that everything
is always going to get twisted and taken
way too seriously glad he's doing that
though it's always uplifting to hear
people working towards their goal let me
think about it blight's five four six
eight let's [__] go
what what a champion
yeah so anyway actually the comments are
mostly really nice and his video the
message is nice so I think thank you to
uh arcadillo
who is the most inspiring Fitness
content yo what do they mean inspiring
were they just like hate on fat people
they like feel Superior by handing on
fat people here's one about Nick ocado
he actually did it Nico Caldo avocado
who has in the last few years made a
living from eating ungodly amounts of
food has been away from YouTube for a
while and now he's back and he has lost
oh for reals
wait just a good amount of weight so far
oh my gosh yeah good for him
okay and actually this video is nice
he's giving props too to Nick remember
people considered him a lost course so
if he can do it anyone can he looks a
million times healthier wow even though
most YouTubers put on an exaggeration I
didn't know he did that video good for
him it really seems like he's more
remember he was eating corn in that
video we watched
oh yeah he was getting down on corn he
was chomping on that are people still
down are his audience still watching him
jump on vegetables yeah people still
watch oh that's great
that's awesome good for him compared to
his old ones it's great to see someone
with such a big audience make a positive
change and again if he can do it anyone
can I like it that was a nice video I
like arcadelio
he's a good man
this is Kate Paul I'm assuming that's a
nickname unless his parents are playing
a prank on him anyways he has started
his weight loss journey and in this
video he does something that almost
everyone wished they did too take
progress pictures from the start wait
why that photo the one with the mom
that's like such an iconic
and you know your boy has a plate of
food right here too for the gains in the
photo that could be like a
like a water that that's so funny it is
a meme oh my God do not want to take
pictures of yourself if you think you
look bad but most people who have ever
achieved a good physique says they
regret not taking more pictures at the
beginning and it's much better to
compare yourself to yourself rather than
someone online who takes steroids and
edits their photos when you get them
motivated and feel like you're slacking
you can lose damn good for you bro okay
this guy's motivating me
we love Arc arcadelio
we love them we love him let's see what
he's saying about this is a video that
let's see what he's saying about uh he's
Norwegian I can hear it on his voice I'm
99 sure
okay interesting
you would know I mean yeah you know we
did it because of the hate comment she
got this is the reason as to why me and
so many other women hate themselves and
their bodies so apparently it's Madison
Beer's fault that you hate yourself just
because she looks better than you don't
get me wrong if someone were to ask okay
I see okay well hey bro keep it up man
you can make a new video about me every
time I lose five pounds bro that's what
it is shout me out please I need all the
help I can get brother call into the
show friend of the show arcadelio
but I'll tell you what man
I'm as I come down on weight as I hope I
continue to and hit my goal of like 180
or something
I will be
should mail up that Dome advocating and
fighting for my fat brothers and sisters
because I know what it's like I know how
hard it is and the fat phobia is [__]
a real thing bro seeing it play out in
front of our eyes people go
I'm I forgive him
I forgive him for being fat
that's crazy
so there it is
pretty fun love that
um
also kind of in the realm of uh
Inspire inspiring I don't know there's a
whole genre now of women who are going
on
these shows like this whatever and fresh
and fit and actually
destroying these [__] losers
it's quite quite great to see so there's
a little context
apparently this guy who she's talking
about he came on to talk about the
importance of self-control that's like
his whole shtick okay
can I ask you one more question far away
um if you have only one place in your
heart for one woman or you want to have
one woman in your heart I think you said
why don't you just commit to one and
choose to be faithful to her
I'm just not wired that way I spent my
whole 20s trying to fix myself
control you you work out you do business
you can possess your own your own power
and just direct it the way
do you think that might be a limited
mindset
I think it's none of your business but I
don't want you to think I'm triggered by
you I'm not yeah
let me just mention that real fast
you're not getting to me right I don't
know who this guy is this is a new
character unlocked but man he looks like
a fish I have more humility than you
exactly same Vibes I just want to let
you know right now you're like
triggering me girl
like nobody said anything about it I
think that might be a limited mindset I
love her business but I don't want you
to think I'm triggered by you I'm not I
saw somebody say that and I think that's
interesting I think you're annoying but
I'm not sure you know what I'm saying no
you are you're annoying bro don't you
see how pathetic you are oh my God
yo
the slightest bit of pushback and like a
fair like pointing out their uh
hypocrisy sends this guy into a total
meltdown yeah she suddenly becomes a
girl who is making no sense not even
worth listening it's annoying yeah
literally she's totally not triggering
me totally not her business none of your
business none of her business on this
show I'm here to talk about literally I
literally came on the show to talk about
it yeah 100 not her business it's goody
two shoes typeway and that's fine uh I'm
gonna live my life on my terms
unapologetically like truly so uh you
can ask me this 85 different ways at the
end of the day I'm gonna walk out of
here the same man
and that's my favorite I refuse to
refuse to change or better myself in any
way it doesn't matter what evidence or
information I'm presented with I promise
I will never change I am incapable I
just want to be left alone just I just
want to be left alone yeah but then
there's actually a little bit of a
wrinkle so
this tweet says in the first time in
Tick Tock history
the chick humiliates the guy and it's
like okay first time in history
but then you go down his
you can see here
he goes his whole message is about
importance of self-control so she said
why don't you control your lust instead
of cheating and shagging loads of
strangers and he resorted to Petty name
calling he got defeated
so oh my God but then I was like wait
wait wait embarrassing he got defeated
in a debate by a female
I was like rip my my Spidey senses
started tingling
that's like losing a war to the French
week
then he goes on
switch off for a sec I want to see what
this image is that's like losing a war
to the French
oh it's not by a British guy I'm pretty
sure the French have defeated British
many
times go ahead you can come back Ian
this and then he goes the solution is
simple men should seek purpose and
validation from God not female genitalia
the real alpha males of this era are
building communities not pumping and
dumping women like their ship coins
here's how it can be done
I was like yo it's just another Alpha
Sigma bro trying to [__] is there's
no escape from this crap out Sigma in
him
he goes like them
oh
the bottom line is this the pursuit of
sexual
Hedonism Hollows out your heart the only
way to feel you have something to worth
living for is to find a cause that's
worth dying for martyrdom is the
Pinnacle of masculinity hold the [__]
phone oh I ain't watering myself
martyrdom that's what he said this man
just took an Isis turn
martyrdom is the Pinnacle of masculinity
then go die bro
self-sacrifice over self-worship men are
Machines of War that's all we are jeez
man
in order for you to find purpose where
you actually need to find an enemy to go
to war with you need to find a dragon to
slay
that enemy should be the devil and his
children that's the real Crusade I was
like oh bro this tweet started off so
good
and then it got so [__] weird
the medication wore off right but
there's actually another girl I'm a fan
of who's been going making the rounds
and destroying
the guys too where's that one here oh
here
uh
here's i s here's some of her on fresh
and fit just destroyed a dress however
you like when you're committed so
satisfying to see uh somebody come on
these shows
I think you should wear whatever you say
something Abby I was saying her name is
Farah
what's the
where's that name from
um it's it's an Arabic name I know that
I know a lot of photos back home
in Dearborn it's all relative like there
are hijabi women who look at our
definition of modern Garb and consider
us [__] and likewise I've heard men
say that they consider their girlfriend
even wearing makeup in a relationship to
be them seeking attention from other men
and I feel like if you just use the male
gaze as guidance you're just being
controlled Haram
so okay so you think they should be able
this man just pushed he this man just
pushed his own sound bite of Andrew Tate
screaming Haram
crazy however they want yeah I mean
obviously if I was dating made
conversation he's talking to her don't
be pushing sound bites on her yeah
you're one-on-one with her man it's
crazy this makes me feel a bit insecure
then I would like be amenable to that
discussion but I don't as a blanket roll
think that like what I wear is a
reflection of my loyalty to him thank
you but wouldn't it be fair to say that
people judge a book by its cover in
today's society
yes and like I said some people judge
that in a very dumb way right in a way
that's a projection of their own
insecurity thank you and again she's
she's hitting on the heart of it these
guys are all deeply deeply deeply
insecure and they cannot they cannot
entertain that I would look at like I
said a girl wearing makeup
I just find it funny when women who wear
these dresses I want to hold the phone
coconuts is actually trying to say some
[__]
like I said a girl wearing makeup
I didn't find the funny when women who
wear these dresses are these like I want
to say revealing revealing outfits and
then they get mad when guys call them or
hit them up and it's like you're wearing
it to attract them yeah I mean so you
think it's okay to dress however you
want Even In A Country he's fun we he's
done he's so nothing going on up there
he I think fit had to be like
he had to fill in the blank he was
trying to think of like reveal or
something and his brain stopped working
oh oh
committed relationship no I'm asking oh
yes
okay would you be
um
so if your guy told you change you would
not change all this in a relationship
you compromise and you do things
for the other person's insecurity but
that doesn't mean that I think it
reflects the security yes [__]
insecurity does that mean my boyfriend
insecure and I value the way he feels
then maybe I would change but it's not
because I think
I have less value dressed in a certain
way in a relationship
do you think it's really insecurity or
more about him trying to make sure that
you
present yourself in a way where people
respect you and don't look at you and
again follow that all the way it's about
how it makes you feel
it make you're you want other men to
validate
uh you because your girlfriend's acting
right
therefore you are seeking approval from
other dudes which is so gay by the way
so insecure
well like I said what do you think
of my boyfriend want to say stop wearing
makeup why are you wearing makeup if you
have a boyfriend unless you're trying to
attract other men do you think that's
people do say that she's absolutely
right I mean that does not equate nearly
to the same level as dressing
provocatively showing your tits and
having your body out is like wearing
makeup it doesn't right like I said it's
relative and in certain cultures they
would consider even wearing a tight
turtleneck provocative yeah but we're
speaking in in general Western cultures
we're not talking about like a
restrictive Islamic Society or something
like that we're talking about like a
general Western culture right common
sense if you're showing your ass your
titties Etc you're over sexualizing
yourself enhancing your beauty is you
know one thing but like sexualizing
yourself is a completely different thing
let's be honest here there's no General
Western culture like what are you
talking about like the standards are
different in Europe than it is like
you're talking about Miami like that's
that's what you know like that and I've
been to Miami dude
I'm saying if you are worried about peop
modesty Miami is not the place for you
right
um
I like how he's trying to split hairs
here he goes let's be real
there's a big difference between
what do you say
right common sense if you're showing
your ass your titties Etc you're over
sexualizing yourself enhancing your
beauty is there's a big difference
between enhancing your beauty
and sexualizing yourself okay what is
the difference dude
one thing but like sexualizing yourself
is a completely different thing let's be
honest here I've seen a video where a
girl walks down the street of Manhattan
for 12 hours wearing a white v-neck tank
top wrapped into jeans yes and people
say she's asking to be cat called would
you consider that a provocative you know
what I love that you use that example
you triggered my trap because you are so
embarrassing
you are so embarrassing
that was brutal you just got owned
laughs
all my homies hate you
dude you were so embarrassing not to
mention just the weather where he's at
too in Miami it's so [__] humid like
obviously people are gonna be wearing
less right
mm-hmm
yeah but um
it's funny because her point was
perfectly made he goes we're according
to Western culture and she goes okay so
what about this women walk around in
jeans and a top
totally acceptable not pushing it
so here's his travel you triggered my
trap because they did that with a woman
that was dressed in a hijab and they did
that with a woman that was just
provocatively even though the woman in
the hijab did get cat called as well it
mitigated the cat call significantly
right but you were saying we choose
Western Norms thank you and the whole
t-shirt and jeans is the default
absolutely and now you're advocating for
the hijab I'm not advocating for the
head job I'm saying if you take we're
taking two extremes here and I'm saying
when you dress extremely modestly it uh
reduced the amount of cat calls
significantly so that standard outfit
white T-shirt Jean she just happens to
have curves is that provocative
here's the thing should she dress like
that if she has a boyfriend that that
that adds even more Credence to what
we're saying because even if you dress
regularly guys are gonna call you so
wouldn't it believe me to think damn if
I dress provocatively it's for real then
that's going to be even worse right and
that default outfit God yeah and don't
dress like that would you consider that
operating out of insecurity
no that's operating out of reality right
no you're insecure she's awesome I love
her
uh she's on Tick Tock at pharah
pharah khalidi
yeah
yeah she's awesome
there's a bunch of uh other ones I don't
know if you guys want to watch they're
all really good
I'll watch one more what's your body oh
yeah she this is when I followed her she
was doing these kind of like uh
comedy videos
and then she started making the rounds
on these all these shows we talked about
eight
disgusting
are you serious
you're basically damaged goods after
letting that many guys hit they were all
women uh
so you're a virgin
yeah
very good
so there it is
love to see it oh we have updates on the
prices sure let's take a look where are
they they're at the top um are you guys
want to know the prices on these
Classics here we go
crew neck wait what that those prices
don't seem right
no those aren't right those are old
those aren't the right prices okay I'll
look
yeah no
no
um
did you get that from Luke
so he
asked him if he got the updated prices
yeah it could be old we'll see
thank you Luke Luke
foreign
thank you Luke
[Music]
uh uh Papa John is cheating on me
you guys [__] believe this
what with this other YouTuber goddamn
Papa's in the house uh what's his name
Danny Duncan Danny Duncan
I don't know much about this Kentucky
Derby [__] but this is the whitest
goddamn thing I have ever seen in my
life look at this they dress up like
they're going to a wedding
to watch horse race
okay and papa by the way the newly
divorced Papa I don't know which one's
his girl but like okay Papa
probably the left one right yeah I'm
assuming maybe that's done Danny's yeah
girlfriend
dude that's so awesome look at papa so
Beauty
let me finish what I said so Beauty yes
look at these dresses yeah no I mean
they you got a stunt on them horses oh
yeah that turns me on uh
Peyton Manning the whitest dude in the
world
needs Papa John
Papa I never said the N word John
[Laughter]
dude this is this is like hell on Earth
I wouldn't angle on that photo [__]
never want to go to this
look at these these women are wearing
like goddamn Plantation hats
you see that mm-hmm
that hat it was racist
got your hat so that's it I just saw
Papa and uh give him a little shout out
by the way ABC fall lineup is crazy you
guys they got inspired by our
ideas on Friday check this out
the elephant gynecologist his hands
might be big but his heart is bigger
[Laughter]
hahaha
no and and uh
Cumberbatch actually that's a big that's
a big get
that's a real doctor strange I I am a
surgeon
uh here the next one Mel Gibson the Mad
chiropractor the voice is in his head
help him fix your back
schizophrenic chiropractor
I like Mel Gibson for that role
this is the
uh the PTSD podiatrist
do not scream do not make sudden
improvements or you might regret it
dude these are so freaking insanely good
oh my God and my favorite one
by the way shout out to purple Axel
these are so funny
this is my favorite one the closeted
urologist
one doctor's purse to accept himself
oh man
I do think that there's something there
the positive urologist I mean there's
something there
deeply closeted but he handles [__] all
day
that's something there you guys
[Music]
thank you it's like Dexter being a cop
right
ironic
uh new Elon Musk meme just dropped he
was caught at a rave in Mexico look at
this [__] get a load of this [__] guy
this guy is like 10 kids right
look at this what are you doing
why are your hands on your head like
that
all right wait oh God
what are you doing dude everyone's just
filming him too look at that
oh brother
he's feeling it
he's letting loose
everyone
that is one strange man right there I
what's the story with the girl you think
she's with him or she's trying to like
get with them or maybe nothing but
there's some interesting connected to
him no just dancing next to each other
maybe yeah maybe not
there's no girls for you on that night
it's him just for the black dance floor
yes that company in public right it has
to be some weird exclusive place
probably
me and her are the only one dancing in
the [__] bar you know
just me and you baby just me and you
tonight
put your head he's he's probably
tripping balls put your hands on your
head
he's getting arrested in his in his uh
he's on mushrooms probably
put your hands on your head but keep
dancing
you must keep dancing with your hands on
your head and we'll shoot
it is incredible how [__] nailed to
the floor his feet are oh man I even
look at his feet they don't they are
[__] fused you're right dude this
looks like a [__] keemstar story man
so I'm grinding with this girl right
Elon Musk is there right he's just
dancing he's not with anyone his his
hands are on his head
um
keep dancing put your hands in the air
put your hands on your head sounds like
uh acoustic version or something like it
doesn't make sense it doesn't
you're right that was fun just a little
fun thing
uh Martha Stewart 81 oldest
cover for Sports Illustrated check out
her
. I'll have what she's having
what's in those cookies and [__] she's
making the same thing
yo she really looking this good at 81.
is this like super airbrushed no I she's
a natural beauty Martha Stewart's always
been beautiful let her cook but 81 man
yeah she's perfect she got cleavage very
gracefully do you think it goes away she
has some work no I don't know but like
you don't see 81 year olds with their
cleavage out usually I'm looking at her
right now coming
I'm coming
holy [__] man
good for her she's so [__] beautiful
jail did her good
mm-hmm
she gonna Live Forever at that pace God
I love her oh she started a Charisma I
didn't know that
wow she's like a different person man
if I saw these two pictures I wouldn't I
wouldn't think it was the same person
I feel like I see it
I see it but skin is the same
did you see it
I don't
I don't uh
someone you guys know Derek Nathaniel
uh dark Nathaniel klansman
someone made AI to try to see what dark
Nathaniel klansman would look like
oh no
I'll tell you what Reddit all the
details
um that's kind of what I was picturing
I'm trying to feel it out
this one you're feeling so far let's see
how much it looks good that one seems
good
um
[Music]
quite look like this one gives me hodoro
Vibes this one I'm not liking yeah
although he looks great pretty crazy
ah yeah sometimes uh
[Music]
is there more keep going
oh interesting very young version yeah
Daniel could see this one maybe
this one's good it's okay
love the overalls and [__] for sure
yeah this guy yeah oh this guy's good
he's the perfect age you know he's
middle aged he's seen some [__] well
I'll tell you man I've seen plenty of
stuff in my day boy
some things I wish I had
got some good memories though some bad
ones too
when I was just a boy
my papa used to wake us up in the middle
of the night
I guess that's where I get all my
peculi realities at you might say
so papa will come wake us up around 3
A.M comes out of bed
we go out in the backyard dig holes
Papa would never tell me what Them Holes
was for but come morning Them Holes was
filled up
one one about but
a decade later I realized what was in
them holes
changed me
changed man
and I always thought my paper was a good
man but
when you look inside them hoes and you
realize what was deep down there
makes you wonder did I ever know the man
[Music]
well anyway as I was talking about that
one time that Jeremiah came
yeah
that's him right
[Music]
okay
nice
I can keep going if you guys want
that we're good
I tell you what man you ever dug a hole
at 3am
put your Pappy behind you
got the flashlight on the back of your
head there says don't turn around now
bar no
the flashlight is so bright if you
turned around you couldn't see nothing
anyway you can't can't do this
yeah
one day he told me getting the hole boy
I said Papa what are you talking about
man it's tired he said boy
get in the hole
something in his voice there
scared me to my core I never thought it
was my papa as a scary man but in that
moment I did what he told me
[Music]
stepped down into the hole he said
that's right boy
lie down in the hole he said to me
oh
oh that was a dark moment for me I laid
there in the hole
it's a beautiful night stared up at the
sky I remember a few passing clouds but
boy you ain't never seen the sky so
pretty as that
right by me seen the Northern Light
hmm
[Music]
thank you
I'll continue his backstory to add
another time yeah I mean small doses
still developing the next time we have a
guest
but I'm sure they'll love that
foreign
let's see here
Aiden Ross wants me to text him
seriously
I think that boat sailed brother you saw
that oh my [__] God bro
oh that hurts
is that why he wants my validation so
bad that's what I was thinking yeah I
mean that's why I kept asking if you
hate him what here he is he looks so
young man okay okay okay this is the
exclusive content we got from his old
classmate correct so this probably trip
him out
yeah what the [__]
sweet this is like uh
yeah weird as [__] chat
oh big trouble and I don't want to be in
big trouble
I don't know how you became there was a
path for you oh my [__] God bro you
could have been one of the good ones but
one of our last yo this is so
interesting that someone sent him this
you're trying to break through to him
don't you think yes yes he is update was
they yeah I feel like this is a cycle
we've gone through several times before
with him
what what's the cycle he said something
crazy yeah and then you talk [__] on him
on the show yeah and then a little bit
of time passes and then you see a clip
of him and you're like I feel like he's
got a good heart I didn't say that he
sees that and I didn't say that or
whatever some version of that I didn't
say I didn't say nothing about nobody
yet and then you guys talk you did go
through all this and then you were going
to meet up before and then it never
happened and then we went back to being
mad at him it's just it's a brutal cycle
that's I didn't realize your shirt your
chair says nice day that's sweet
yes yes are you uh having like a relapse
and saying all that uh
recent stuff he's been doing was as a
result this music chat what the hell
path to the light for him is he off the
internet love maybe you know since he
put out that I've relapsed I've been
taking some time off Ethan why don't you
text me huh
well I haven't heard anything since then
so it's even possible no he's still
streaming yeah he's still on he was
talking [__] about uh I show speed's new
song that came out the other day
I'm not gonna lie bro it's bad chat
ever since that Vegas IRL streams I
think I've only done like three streams
bro it's [__] I gotta get on my
consistent [__] chat why do y'all not
motivate me bro like what the [__] we
know all I know bro
he's lost
look at you man you're like you you look
up to Andrew Tate but what has he done
for you yeah you can't even stream
you're so unmotivated and [__]
come on dude come to the light side bye
over it not doing the cycle anymore Dan
he's cut off [__] you I will not be
texting you
will not be damning you I break the
cycle I will not be this is a cycle of
abuse
you've been given too many chances
thank you so much
and that turns into a circle
we tried I really did you know
oh new PMP video
let's [__] go please by the way PMP
is calling it on Friday
let's go I want to talk to him about a
few things
oh God we have we were planning our live
show it's I think we got some funny
ideas
yeah just made me think yeah I'm stroke
now okay what yeah I said yeah I'm
stoked now me too did we ask PNP about
that idea yet is he in or do we not know
yet
I don't know I loved our idea for PMP
he's the best
let's go so serious and complicated
criminal case no jail we're right
outside of Rancho Cucamonga courthouse
where we scored big uh at the outset of
this case was really tough I'll tell you
we had multiple victims we had multiple
charges we had a lot of jail on the line
but I'm proud to announce that today we
took a good deal no jail and this is
going to be off his record in no time
how do you feel go great you got me off
the worst thing I could have probably
imagined it was like you're walking to a
burning rack for me you just saved me
from all these charges I don't have to
pay anything it's it's really perfect
like I'm free I'm good I'm free baby I
noticed something peculiar about this
video David is not specific at all
about the crimes only that there was
many victims you're right wait a minute
yeah you watch this back yeah he's watch
it again with that in mind he he's
concealing the truth of how [__]
heinous this guy is all right let's see
all right we're right outside of Rancho
Cucamonga first of all I can't I still
have a hard time believing that Rancho
Cucamonga is a real place
it's like 20 minutes from here I know
but the name is what the [__] that's
where I was on Friday I was in Rancho
Rancho cucamongo
it's called Rancho cucamongo
that's fun do you feel like do you feel
that way because Bugs Bunny would use it
as like a funny sounding place all the
time that was yeah I didn't even know
that in the old Looney Tunes
that's awesome
all right let's let's flash your house
where we scored big uh at the outset of
this case is really what now I want you
to notice something he's doing in his
eyes watch closely as he says
he tries to convey you just how [__]
up this [__] is enough I'll tell you we
had multiple victims we have oh wait no
sorry I missed it hold on multiple where
we scored big
uh at the outset you see that whoa yeah
that's telling this guy's a [__]
Menace to Society really tight look at
his eyes here
really tough I'll tell you we had
multiple victims we had multiple victims
multiple charges we had a lot of jail on
the line but I'm proud to announce that
today we took a good deal no jail and
this is going to be off his record in no
time how do you feel go great you got me
off the worst thing I could what did he
do
[Music]
what could he have done with multiple
victims huge jail time
could have been drunk driving hit drunk
hit and run with injuries something like
that could definitely get you put away
for a long time and he's like I'm happy
to say I'll be back driving uh right now
headed to the bar to celebrate celebrate
yeah
and it's gonna be off my record
s you imagine it was like you're walking
to a burning rack for me you just saved
me from all these charges I don't have
to pay is that a is that a clue I walk
burning right burning wreck you just
saved me from all these charges I don't
have to pay anything it's really perfect
like I'm free I'm good I'm happy there's
no one better than this guy he sick all
the time in the world for me he is the
best nothing else you can ask
let's go that's right oh okay well but
he was happy about it at least yeah so
there's David
the first time he's never oh wait he
wait there's info here hold on
clients charges looked like a laundry
list
multiple victims were involved including
one off-duty police officer hand on head
emoji
the prosecutors were not sympathetic at
all for a client who felt the full force
of his own government coming after him
not his own government
what a betrayal I know
at least if the Mexican guy are like the
you know Italy's coming from my own
government Prosecuting me this is [__]
after doing a deep dive into the cases
voluminous evidence
which included many written reports
statements in over 35 separate videos
what happened
35 videos we're able to find several
holes in the prosecution's case
it was like you're walking into a
burning wreck for me he said our client
burning wreck or not our job is always
the same never leave Stones unturned and
don't give up let's go my man
my client was filmed by 35 different
angles committing this crime and HD
clarity
but uh we discovered that one of the
cops that arrested him uh registration
was uh expired
therefore
they had no choice but to let them let
them go oh that's awesome multiple
victims maybe they're comments dude
multiple victims unfortunately
what did he do fortunately
yo what did he do someone asked David
says can't disclose without further
client consent because I forgot to in
the video but it was bad
wait
we've got to contact him ask him to
reach out to the guy give him consent so
he can tell us we need to know we need
to know I'm invested here
but did this guy allegedly do
everybody's invested man
the whole family
this is insane for Crim lawyers to be
honest it sure is that's our boy you new
here or what
oh [__] he's the best man he's such a
character
oh no I just found his new client oh no
not Nathaniel
serious and complicated criminal case no
jail time we had multiple victims
Nathaniel klansman he should be in jail
PMP I can't support that one right
that's actually a cameo from from a
series that isn't real it's a true
season of True Detective coming out
I missed that first season of that show
so good
you know
fun stuff good times huh good times
the lady rushes The Judges Bench
meanwhile during a Content Court
yo that's crazy
oh my God okay that's not gonna help you
yo but that's crazy to judge can just
put her ass in jail for 10 days for
talking back that's crazy
10 days just got turned into like a year
though I read that I think it got uh
turned to 130. 130 days God that's a
long time
I'm sorry 100 yeah 120. well she really
did [__] up oh yeah you don't want to
you know charge a judge
[__] that 10 days moved to 120 and faces
new charges
oh man
what a world huh
a guy pushing a shopping cart on
Rollerblades eat [__]
this is right up my alley
this is right up my alley love this
yes dude yes okay okay okay all right
what
what's the exit strategy here hell
is there sound or is it just like
copyrighted music
I mean I've seen Jackass do this though
run pretty fast
I don't think jackass sounded like that
though that guy needs a new jaw and well
it slams into his back oh that guy's
gonna need to know everything
yeah I don't remember jackass going this
fast no
you know this video is so much better
than last week's ones because last week
there was victims this is just stupidity
so we can just enjoy it without any
issues no moral issues here that's a
good point just enjoy I don't feel bad
at all no me neither
boom tell us why
this is you know what this is how hard
it is out there these guys instead of
finding a job would rather do this
try to get famous
you know it's a tough life out there
it's not easy
we got a new Lizzy in the Box we got a
new Lizzy in the Box coming out of
Scotland
[Music]
hell yeah
that's a nice ditty they got
[Music]
combination
not as if fancy as Lizzy in a box
that [__] still shocks me just how
callous it is
[Music]
oh I'm like this what's the matter you
guys don't like a party
you don't like old sausage fingers
we got a new Fresh uh uh singer falling
off stage gent genuine
oh this is awesome yeah this one's
really good he tries to take this dude
with me
he tries to take this dude with him
which would have been
real bad oh he's the sign language dude
hell yeah how are you gonna sign that
one yo
yo you gotta let him go you can that man
was ready to take him to the end he
wasn't gonna let go of him
it's kind of like genuine National look
at he's trying to kill that man
oh that's [__] good
yeah get back to work bro
[Applause]
this guy rules
well they're probably just roasting him
with the sign language this dumbass
that's attempted murder
I don't care what anybody says
very good
very good uh mobility scooter in the
rain
you know
gotta hit our Mobility Scooter quota
[Music]
that thing's fast man that's gonna be a
Mobility Scooter can it be oh no
yo what the [__]
what
yeah that [__] ain't stuck
we got some mods on it say what so that
thing has to be modded yeah yeah I I bet
they gotta know the guy right that'd be
crazy just to laugh at somebody like
that
that's making the sound
Reckless that's there to that that's
what that is I don't know what I doubt
this is what Kavanaugh did
all right let's move on that's all the
fun stuff at the top now we got serious
stuff to talk about the buggy versus
wings of redemption fight I'm happy to
announce that Boogie did not die
yeah which means
that uh my jokes survived the weekend
it was pretty interesting though uh I'm
I won't lie
here's a let's see I think I believe
keemstar even tweeted out he gives
permission for people to watch this
didn't he say that yeah it's right here
number six all right keemstar
here this is what he said
don't [__] don't at me [__]
Boogie and wings pulled 400k concurrent
viewers
could be closer to one mil if the
unofficial react streams were calculated
no
all creators have permission to use the
full fight footage for reaction okay
[__] W Keem all creative that's nice
one of them don't say [__] to me
actually it is it is a dub I'm glad I
mean it's cool he said that although
something tells me he gave Ryan
Kavanaugh very different uh
advice considering we know that they met
around the time he sued me is that weird
all right so this is a trap
I think that's well he probably doesn't
own the footage I don't because that's
own it's Misfits like why who is he to
give permission
right
well in that case then should we should
we take his word on that
well it is it's not his permission
listen
this commentary is fair use just like
the first time we did it
okay
eat your heart out yeah so here's Boogie
uh uh versus Wings Redemption
this is a real interesting fight
they're they're
bragging that this is the heaviest fight
of all time
over 800 pounds or something yep
and that's an official record eh 800 yep
800.
oh my goodness
now as we predicted
Wings to Redemption actually looking
good
like watch as he feigns some Jabs watch
his [__] he goes jab jab boom dude
that's good yeah that's what I was
saying this man can move all right
Butterbean but right Boogie is out of
his element in fact I think Wings
Redemption might have a future here
look at this he's like where are you at
yo
so I think Boogie attempted one punch in
this whole fight
wow I know I know I'm I'm kind of
interested in his mannerisms throughout
he's trying to tell him to chill or
something but he's like it's happening
dude
taking a step back look at his face he's
like yo why'd you hit me right this
would be me I'd be like dude what the
[__] was that all about dude rude that's
the most uncommon I mean the most common
thing new boxers do is close their eyes
I had a problem with that for a long
time closing my eyes because the end is
natural yeah to turn your head and close
your eyes right
but uh you can tell that bogey did zero
zeroed preparation for this and it seems
like wings actually
right AB I mean
I mean I mean he practiced something not
traditional like when he had his but I
don't know either was I was when I was
in the ring so going for body shots
so watch Boogie he's like the [__] is
going on man this [__] sucks
believe this is real damn this should
actually hurt so they're they're about
to tape him I can't believe it's working
okay so we'll wait for this Zack uh at
this point Boogie's pants are falling
down and they have to duct tape his
pants up
yes where they arrived on mobility
scooters
yeah yeah that was pretty funny it's
kind of funny
pants there
you get a close-up here Zach
[Music]
the strings aren't working so they have
to get
they have to get some kind of tape
right I guess maybe that is because he
lost some weight
okay you know weight loss King yeah
shorts
oh Keem had almost a funny joke here
here goes
he goes training for this fight it looks
like they're taping him I'm not taping
those shorts
no no jokes
London crowd from seeing a full moon
okay
let's take a full moon on a boogie night
yeah yeah and it looks like they're
taping him up here taping his pisses off
to him this is what I'd like
Kim goes this is awesome this is what I
love to see
is this a boxing match what are we doing
here
look here Zach
there you go see what you can do what
you gotta do you know energy
to believe it yeah that's what people
said but Keem had a vision and he made
it possible shot all right shout out
keemstar
I mean this is better concert than he
usually right any drama alert he needs
this man he is a future
[__] he's found his medium listen
apparently both these guys are notorious
recluses and it's not easy to travel
when you're that size so everyone was
saying at least one of them is going to
bail so the fact that he actually made
this happen does seem to be somewhat
impressive
[Laughter]
exactly that is just Zach that is
inappropriate what what next did they
throw him out with a parachute
my cargo
oh
[Laughter]
come on now
oh man it's one of those moments I feel
like somebody clicked
I didn't say nothing no you're good
you're good you're kidding nobody I mean
listen
they're there to be a spectacle
everybody knows what's going on here
they're they're huge I mean everybody
knows that that's why this is happening
[Laughter]
[Music]
man I have a lot of love I have a lot of
love and support for them for their size
[__] a dude I think Boogie's kind of
a douche
besides the size thing that's got
nothing to do with it
just patiently waiting but Wings is
not bad no he's a beast Boogie is like
got some athleticism to him buggy he's
just getting his ass beat dude I mean
let's remember what Boogie was what 15
years older than him and he's like 11
11. and he's going on it's like 49
verses it's really not fair 48 verse 37.
yeah what is the weight difference
between them
I think it's like 40 pounds
around there
oh man well you know what they say
wouldn't you get Ultra heavy weight the
weight doesn't yeah 200 and up yeah it
doesn't matter we don't we don't
distinguish
oh we made it he latched it around right
that's got to be a victory in itself
right you made it through the first
round to be very proud of themselves
these are one minute rounds by the way
Winks doesn't even look that tired I'll
be honest right
poor Boogie he's not he's just there
to get his ass beat so the fact that
we're in round two is just he's just a
human punching bag really I'm telling
you about 60 seconds dude this punch is
probably [__] hurt yeah man a lot of
power behind them yeah dude
that's for damn sure
[Laughter]
so the question is how much more can he
take how much more of the pressure he's
been taking so many shots that round and
then then they got it doing dirty with
this shot oh come on back to the taping
see lands the punches and do some damage
back to Wings we're about to find out
[Music]
Boogie's just gotta go for it he's gotta
get back at that Harry punch in
yeah he needs a Falco punch key I don't
hear he's trying to throw a punch so you
okay okay got some tabs in there he's
throwing something all right that Little
Mac charger punch
[Music]
oh man oh okay all right all right yo
standing eight there we go that's the
right ball there no absolutely fine
[Music]
there it is that was the right call from
the round
that was the right he's getting booed oh
by the Wrath
they don't like that they called it I
mean it's probably was uh and Boogie's
best interest there yeah even Keem was
saying so so you're gonna be eating good
tonight boy
those people wanted blood
yeah they'll be hungry I mean they just
did an athletic event yeah
I am not laughing I am not laughing
bro I just did a whole speech about how
I love and support the fatties
as one
right but I don't think I'm
contradicting myself here
at all
but I think it was the right goal and
yeah respect to these big men for
getting in there I mean absolutely
well this is all about entertainment and
Kim you've outdone yourself for this
Main Event well it's it's it's about
doing the impossible and that's what
this fight was from the very beginning
to the training the the diet everything
was impossible and it actually took
place it actually happened you know what
respect for actually you know what
respect for Boogie oh yeah definitely
without a doubt that ain't that ain't
easy
to get out there and just get in the
ring get your ass beat
so good for him he actually did you know
what I mean good for him Mega dub you
know a boogie definitely at a
disadvantage physically coming into this
match he's got to be proud of himself
for making it through that round he
tanks so much you know he could have
gone down right away to one of those
punches but he stood there he took it if
he if he fell I genuinely think there
would have been a ambulance
I'm not I'm not even saying that maybe
you know
you can't follow that size bro you're
[__] pop like a water balloon
we got paid right yeah he said he that's
why he did it okay so hey
get the money blast it around and that's
good yeah Wings had full control from
the very you know what I'm not even
kidding I would like to see Wings fight
again I would watch him fight again
It's probably hard to find other
opponents damn though I disagree I've
seen some similar stuff at Walmart I
Walmart parking lot yeah you've seen
this playoffs
but in the Creator space yeah maybe he's
quite a bit bigger than Boogie like
height wise yeah
why do they hate each other
I don't think they hate each other
I think they're just doing schtick
they're friendly yeah
yeah we know who won
it's our boy
the wings of redemption who we love now
redeemed he's redeemed I don't know what
he did but you've got to watch that down
the rabbit hole on him it's really good
okay really good truly as an interesting
and bizarre character
and good sports we love that oh cut out
right before
so that was uh the big fight of the
weekend everybody
apologies for those uh jokes on my
behalf of just I got a little lost in
the sauce
okay this is actually [__] great I
was super curious how much she got paid
I was wondering was it like 3 000 or is
it fifty thousand so he said
uh he got 10 000 Cash Plus sponsor deals
free travel and room to London
I don't know that that counts as pay man
it's the least they could do
a few perks that we can't disclose yet
all the self-respect I ever needed
[__] you he but wait he says ah oh no oh
my God he had to pay for his own
training
after medical and training I came out
negative
what
dude you guys don't watch movies don't
sign your soul to the devil this [__]
happens every time it gets you
so you didn't get paid they just paid
for you to
subsidize part of your training in
medical basically dude um
this watching these these fights makes
me realize how professional the Creator
Clash is yeah yeah like these fights are
[__]
medieval
they're yo find me the clip of the dude
doing the spin punch that cracked me up
so much oh yeah that was
I'm sorry this guy said I respect Boogie
less for that fight I disagree
I disagree with that
I respect him for getting in there
it's actually really [__] up that he
actually lost money for risking his life
hey there's keemstar for you baby yeah
like how much
so much money
and mind you also their fight was a big
pull everyone was wanted to I didn't
give a [__] about anyone else who was
fighting
I was there for Boogie vs Wings what's
up baby I was gonna say Ian and Nisa
they pulled it off their first time too
like it's not like
if you're just not a piece of [__] I
feel like you could pull it off also no
problem it wasn't easy but also their
events for charity and they still you
guys still have all your training
covered and us and paid too
right
yeah we got uh whatever was left over
from the the training money
but they also paid you a little bit
don't they
uh yeah we got a little bit of a of a
little bonus yeah
and it's for charity these guys made a
[__] load of money and Kim's like
it's only one fight in him you know
let's burn his ass to the ground and
check out this is the quality of
fighting that's happening at the misfit
events bro I cannot watch this
hard and every time Zucker gets that
moment
[Music]
that was so beautiful this is a boxing
match you've got to do a spinning
backhand
yeah I mean it's crazy ballerina boxing
it's insane counters
counters times Zucker gets that
why does he move so well it's just nuts
it's Swift it's quick also he almost
hits the ref and he slams him in the
back of the head it's just so wild
holy [__] man oh and then KSI [__]
hell about his opponent in the face
knocked him out
and he's still got the win
they didn't even penalize him for it you
gotta you gotta pull that up
and every time Zucker gets that moment
I'm sorry that is just so out of pocket
defending back
it is so ridiculous look at it he
[__] hit him in the back of the head
he made the choice to do that spin
around oh yeah that was his secret move
yeah that was just Achilles Hill did
nobody tell him you're not allowed to do
that
counter's hard this man thinks it's
Mortal Kombat
[__] here and then here is a
oh this is what I just opened yeah
counter's hard this is so [__]
goodbye
[Music]
[Laughter]
listen to the announcer's reaction whoa
a spinning backhand
we don't see that every day out here
every time Zucker gets that moment
oh you got to get me the KSI elbow that
[__] was insane isn't suckles part of
misfit's crew too it's like yeah
organizers
I think one of their own is out there
doing backs [__] spinning backhands
yo so here's KSI yo checking this out
KSI got this knockout
okay
and then took the dub the judges didn't
say anything
and he's just like no I didn't elbow him
watch this
[Applause]
slo-mo it's so fast yeah
there's certain angles oh you can find
me angles
where he's just straight elbowing him in
the [__] face yeah
check this out
his life and that was it and then it was
only when I went backstage so I haven't
seen the replay at this point and you
know I was talking to slim and Dean the
great uh before I went backstage and
they were like yeah nice KO but I think
it was an elbow and I was like what I
just know where I would elbow him why
would I do that it just makes no sense
like I'm winning the fight I can
understand if I'm losing the fight and
I'm desperate and you know even then I'm
like how would I elbow and it not look
like intentional it's just weird so I
went by looked at it and I was like yeah
just show I just want the slow-mo I
think I just found it yeah from the
difference so here it is
yeah yeah oh are these two different
ones I guess the one I sent is the one
that you sent us the other night okay
cool
watch this [__]
Jesus
let's have a look right here oh I mean
he's just straight up elbowed him in the
[__] face
and then
it's spectacular nobody says anything oh
the judges don't say anything I mean to
be honest
when we watched it in real time it was
so [__] quick that I'm not totally
surprised that they didn't realize at
the time what I mean is there occasional
judges come on
everybody was talking about it oh my God
I I don't think it was intentional
though I think no I don't either I don't
either it's just missed hook it looks
like
I don't think it was intentional but I
just thought it was funny like
I don't know enough about boxing to know
like
because the fact that they were sort of
you had the other guy had his arm around
him I don't know if that makes it okay
in that particular circumstance or what
well most people are saying it should
have been no contest which basically
means it's just like a wash and I guess
KSI agrees after seeing the the playback
which is good okay it looks like I just
hit him with my elbow and like
oh uh you know in my forearm and I'm
like
at that point I'm just devastated that's
all I think about and I'm like this is
ruined all my hard work like just it's
it's so annoying because I work so hard
and then you know I well like I look
back at the fight and I look so good
second round I did everything right and
I believe them yeah I mean I
the little bit of the rest of the fight
that I saw he definitely looked really
good and from what I was reading
everybody thought he was easily winning
anyway yeah so that does kind of you can
even talk you can tell in the clip that
he's
he's dominating him yeah so I guess just
bad luck but I just find it so funny
that like they're like yeah no it's fine
and then apparently
one more time [__]
every time Zucker gets that moment
I'm not sure whoa okay how that should
be immediate disqualification right
because he actually elbowed him in the
back of the head that's super dangerous
every
and he almost hits the [__]
[Music]
oh man that's [__] great
there was a the last Misfits someone
tried to headbutt somebody you remember
that yeah that event is crazy
but I guess that's why they love it
a little wild it's a little strange
you ever watch hey dude if you can't go
to the Zone then you can't get along wow
yeah you can't get it done
they always hated it yippee me too yeah
yeah I hated them
what like the Cowboys I can't believe
you remember the whole song I don't know
why I [__] I just remember the part
where they were like hey dude watch out
for those killer cacti and tumbleweeds
hey dude yeah I hated that show so awful
horrible whose idea was it to make a
show for kids about a dude ranch bro you
didn't expect me to go from Watching
Rugrats yeah to hey dude yeah for people
that are a little bit younger than us it
was the show on Nickelodeon when we were
kids it was a live action and it was
like a sitcom about kids working on a on
a ranch
j-r-h-n-br there it is oh yeah dude what
a weird oh separation
she's famous that's uh
who isn't that the girl from
[__] I remember them now
so such a blast from the past you know
look how terrible that graphic is they
made look at that horseshoe
like y'all couldn't try harder than that
well it was like 1991 or something her
her she's she's way famous oh you're
[__] right that's Ben Stiller's wife
ex-wife yeah Taylor that was her big
break she was on hate Sasha Brady yeah
that's right Marshall Brady that's right
yeah from the movie not from from the
movie yeah hey dude damn it's a big
break I never realized that you think
that song's caught can you see if that
song gets claimed because I want to
[__] wrong with that almost it
definitely will right who's claiming
that [__]
hey dude theme song I'm The literally
the only person that remembers the
lyrics to that yeah I'm shocked I
remember the or not the only one this
has 1.3 million I remember the uh Salute
Your Shorts theme song you remember that
ones
Tommy for me how's it going starts camp
anawana we hold you in our hearts there
it is and when I think about you it
makes me wanna fart oh no and then it
goes it makes me want to to Art say it
right or pay the price yes exactly Bud
the camp counselor right
yeah you always had the
the sunscreen on us now God man those
were the days boy
um those were the days hey dude
such a Carefree that time to be alive
man
um
you know what show was from that same
era that actually was so [__] good
though
Pete and Pete you remember that one I do
remember Pete I loved that show when I
was a kid yeah I [__] loved that show
Nickelodeon was a crit was a wild Place
back then boy it got claimed it got
claimed yeah who was claiming this
Nickelodeon bro pro move on like let me
listen let me let me live my life move
on
I'm so disappointed
it's a little while it's a little
strange
when you're at home out on the Range
yeah okay it is sounding a little more
familiar now there's a rational right if
you can't come along if you can't get a
ride then you see your new song
singing yippee Kaya yay
what like the Cowboys say
send to my ear now
yippee-kai it's exclaimed by treasure
teens you get it got blocked they
blocked it yeah
yo chill worldwide block whoa chill
not that serious
glad we did that can you imagine getting
the whole episode blocked for that [__]
[__] that Daddy chill
yeah so there it is there it is
congratulations to Wings of redemption
who soared his way
would you call what he did soaring uh
Zach
would you say wings of redemption soared
his way to Victory
back
um pleading the fifth here think
carefully
[Music]
cargo dropped his way to Victory
resupply incoming
go ahead
can you pull this off I can't see Zach
formulating his thoughts uh
again your honor I'm gonna plead the
fifth one okay
thank you
we got uh Mr Beast neighborhood have we
not talked about this before
I don't believe we already had an FBI
agent I recreated Willy Wonka's
Chocolate we are currently surrounded by
countless sharks
Is that real love yeah
yeah okay so wait so wait wait wait
yes yes yes dude it's
okay so love read read it
so I got an email from my lawyer just
just literally during the show so I've
been like having some back and forth
and I just got uh my non-immigration
Visa application issued
official
[Applause]
bruh one of us one of us one of us
wait we're [__] America wait you said
you said non-immigration Visa yeah every
everything is it's it's done dude it's
GG it's I got it what immigration means
you're like moving here permanently is
that that man I gotta I gotta I got a
Visa for
um it's the Mercury so that's going
through yeah okay so it's a
non-immigration VISA which means you
can't live here permanently right it's
three years although you can if you just
if you if you work here for us for three
years you can apply for green card I
think I didn't want you out for a while
then when you have a green card for
three years you can apply for
citizenship that's what ELO did yeah oh
he's coming home
he's coming home yeah get that Swedish
one out of here we got Chick-fil-A and
Taco Bell waiting here for you boys
hit that R Kelly hey bro what's your
shot status oh oh yeah I'm just stopping
boys stop by he's got it bye
I'm not gonna sing it
[Music]
girl would you like to come back with
love to America
this is me to love
America
do you have your past passport did you
get yourself girl would you like to come
back with these things to America yes
I'm coming I'm coming
[Music]
what
oh come on
I made it dude I made it
oh my God
I got it dude [__] that's crazy he's
coming home that's one and a half years
in the making holy Mom God damn he's
coming home
uh we're out of room so
I don't know I've got to set you up a
permanent see it in here love
sure we'll figure it out well we did
talk about the idea of keeping you on
the bloodbot and you're just sitting
yeah you could be a holiday closet yeah
I'd be at home there's plenty of space
around here I need I need a friend back
here anyways too that's true the cam and
love show little mini show back there
what's the first thing you're gonna do
when you arrive in uh when you get here
uh well I've gone on that question so
many times but it's kind of anti-romatic
I I just want to be there without
stressing without like having to always
think about am I gonna get I just
literally want to be there it's weird
just wants to exist
yeah I want to live but also Chick-fil-A
and that's what I was like
all that [__] yeah buy an AR-15 is
pretty good advice from Dan yeah right
right is she is an immigrant allowed to
buy a hell yeah I got 15. I have rights
I have rice Garden yeah no I know you're
gonna buy an intervention from Modern
Warfare I have no idea if that's true or
not I bet they can't why you know I mean
it's America
I doubt my brother-in-law Muhammad could
get one
Muhammad could no not Muhammad but love
could love could get a whole ass Arsenal
very nice
a valid alien registration or I-94 card
is required at the time of purchase of a
firearm so you're good
brother
that's [__] awesome
oh this is crazy thank you everyone for
making this possible yes uh yes
it's weird
I guess uh time to start making some
plans and then I don't know how long
it's going to take you but but uh so I'm
gonna start making some plans oh yeah
boy I'm gonna be
making plans all right
sad to see you go I know you live with
that you know what my parents are
extremely extremely supportive of
whatever I choose to do so they're very
sad of course but they've been nothing
but support they're happy because you're
happy
exactly lovely I didn't realize as a
parent it's both the bitter sweetness of
your child achieving what they want and
also
you're not seeing them your parents are
gonna have to come visit be on the show
and stuff oh yeah oh okay maybe not the
second part well
your dad sounds awesome
if I remember
you at home all right
I love my parents
that's good wow very exciting
very exciting yeah and thank you guys
for making this is very very exciting
very very like this is like people say
is you get life-changing news this is
literally life-changing I'll be moving
my life is like forever changing it's
yeah yeah that's wild pretty crazy
pretty crazy
I heard it and if you're looking for a
place I heard the Cecil has really good
rates
I've heard about too
I wonder how much it actually costs to
do a month in Cecil it's uh it's a
homeless shelter now I believe oh you
can't even stay there no you can't you
have to be homeless
well technically you're homeless
yeah I am a homeless or yeah yeah
if you need a place to stay when you
arrive you can stay with us
really yeah well you're probably gonna
need a place to crash right until you've
figured yeah for the first couple days
definitely I told you two weeks
I've always told a lot of years two
weeks you can stay with us that's it
Max you can stay with us as long as you
need we have a we have a guest house
where it's separate and you'll have
privacy and you can do whatever you want
there from everywhere perfect thank you
thank you appreciate it of course
God bless internet sucks though it's not
that bad in there
if you're trying to play COD or whatever
just just adds up
um because I know the priority you know
we'll see we'll see y'all
wow okay you don't know that Dan
I do know that you're talking [__] at my
pool house the internet no your whole
house the internet kind of sucks what
yeah that's [__] don't listen to him
no I'm not why would you lie like that
I'm not lying I think I'm worse in your
house for like two years oh because
right well we did the we did all we
hosted a whole last yeah [__]
operation from my from my residential
internet that's not that's pretty good
you know big difference between that
world why are you slandering my internet
you want that low ping the service is
horrible but I haven't had problems with
the internet there Jesus Christ he's
offering me a place to live chill out
dude yeah I'm uh I'm gonna accept that
with um Open Arms yeah
uh I'm gonna you know what no love I'm
gonna talk to uh I don't I don't
remember who's my service driver I'm
gonna talk to them I'm gonna make sure
that that pool house is buzzing oh yeah
dude that's awesome
uh this is Gracie well I've not
processed it yet I I will be doing some
crying after the Stream
[__]
thank you
we'll have to hit up Dave and Busters
and [__] when you get here [__] come on
you guys going next week or when was it
I'm heading up now
we'll go okay we'll do that Saddle Ranch
Dave and Buster
God damn dude we can go
to Taco Bell yeah sit in the restaurant
damn I'm gonna start food prepping with
Taco Bell like I did before too oh [__]
I did that [__] I like bought a bunch
and I put it in my fridge no I remember
you said that that's pretty wild brother
you live in that young man's life boy
how old are you you're like 23 I'm 22.
yeah yeah that's a that's a young man's
game meal prepping yeah right I got a
couple couple years left yeah you've got
a solid like three years before that
starts to you start to feel the
repercussions of that around 25. yeah
yeah yeah I'll worry about that later oh
for sure I mean I used to I used to meal
prep [__]
when I was in college and I was living
on my own
or I was in a house with a bunch of
people but I had my own room and we
didn't really talk to each other
but what I would do is
I would do this crazy buy one get one
and I would store an ungodly amount of
pizza
probably could feed 20 people hell yeah
and I would eat it all over the course
of a week
that's what's up I do that
um but if I if I did that now
I I don't even know how to describe it I
think I that I would probably die
I would be having diarrhea I would be
having crazy heartburn
I would be feeling like slow you might
find me dead you're describing me right
now last night and I feel like [__]
[__] today you had pizza last night I
had the [__] runs multiple times I
have an awful heartburn that's it that
happens to me I can't even eat pizza
anymore without a dire consequence but
you're so right though I never had this
before I turned 25. exactly before 25
you're like what's wrong with pizza it's
great right fuel it's energy I feel
great yeah no it's it's [__] shitty
now not the style you guys
I had an entire Red Baron frozen pizza
to myself yesterday and I'm feeling
great today
well it's vegetarian
I think it's that just like no pepperoni
that makes you know what there are
different levels of of heaviness because
if you order out they go so [__] hard
with the grease and the bread yeah
those frozen ones are
got to be like a third of the calories
of like one of those so maybe it's not
really the same as Slam in a dominoes or
whatever but it props to you for being a
man of the people and eating a frozen
pie
some [__] problems you're a good
[__] man for doing that did you
microwave it or put in the oven no oven
you got to do the oven microwave yeah
why would you say that there's uh
there's there's little crazy [__]
people out there I don't know I mean
there are those little are you one of
them God no I have a nice air fryer
though okay that's cool love that that's
nice love you know
you know this is crazy and to make it
even crazier I've never lived alone
I've lived with my parents up until now
they're a young man it's like you're
going after mileage yeah that's a big
jump and I'm you're like a dependent on
me now bro you know that hello hell yeah
I've gotta like [__] look out here
and [__] own you we're gonna be left
alone you you know what if you like go
[__] if you kill someone I think that
might come back on me
well I won't kill anyone but no
seriously or well if he like if he runs
up a bunch of debt and like disappears I
think I have to pay it off what because
you're like sponsoring him or whatever
yeah yeah yeah oh sure no you each for
sure so but but also the other way
around if you fire me I'm out
okay I like that um there you go right
you better be you better stay that
simple
boy uh I will I will is that right if I
fire you have to leave
yeah yeah yeah that's hardcore yeah
that's why um
[__] Elon Musk is so [__] up firing
a bunch of people on Twitter because a
lot of those employees were from like um
firing them and they would get yeah oh I
didn't know that angle just upending
their whole lives
it's crazy
well I'm so excited I'm happy for you
love you're a good man thank you
and uh
a valued part of the family
very excited
yep what if I get
what if I get permanently banned I guess
I'm still technically employing you as
long as I'm paying you right yeah
exactly as long as we're unemployed well
you have a you have a more vested
interest than even any of these guys in
making sure I don't care we got to give
love the button yeah yeah yeah I'll take
control of the bottoms
oh that's funny wow awesome man
congratulations yeah congrats thank you
that's so cool
very cool yeah you can stay with us as
long as you need it's all good I
appreciate that I appreciate that thank
you no pressure very much do you have a
license
yeah you do driver license yeah yeah oh
yeah so so we're gonna have to get you a
car and [__]
you need a car in L.A right
or I mean you guys have multiple cars
right I can just borrow one
you can take mine love oh I should thank
you I don't have any cars going spare
for you at the moment God damn don't
even have spares not I I enjoy cars so
I'm gonna find a nice nice car on my own
yeah I think it's easy to convert the
license I think you don't have to do any
tests or anything I don't think from
what I've yeah I think so too yeah
I wonder what's the driving like here
compared to Sweden like you know you
know
um cam drove me around a lot and it's
very different but I I think I'm fine I
I have I've been driving motorcycles
cars for ever since I was like 14 so I
should be good
how is it different
uh well more it's just more more yeah
yeah okay driving at the time
right there's that aspect too yeah the
man was a new driver oh that makes it
even that's intense
yeah he did good he did good for being a
new driver I can't imagine being a new
driver in L.A geez I don't think we ever
talked about that on the show but yeah I
got my license the week before I moved
here for my job oh [__] yeah la is a
[__] crazy place to drive
yeah there's the thing that that's like
besides everyone driving like super fast
and Maniacs on the freeway and just tons
of cars there's exits here
the amount of exits and freeway changes
and stuff can really [__] you
yeah no yeah I noticed when I was
driving with Cam but I I think I'm good
yeah
hours so yeah
There It Is Love
what a day
there it is
congrats man thank you thank you
well uh speaking of employees having
moving we're going to talk about Mr
BEAST's neighborhood
I like that you picked up the sound
about exactly where you cut it off
good continuity there Zach
so people are okay so so the story is I
guess that Mr Beast brought like a bot a
whole ass neighborhood
in North Carolina for him his family and
his employees to live in
some people are calling it cult-like
now I know property in North Carolina is
a lot cheaper than here in La so I don't
know
I think it's like 200 000 for a house
there is that right he bought his house
in 2018 for uh 300K 320k I gotta say it
that's like insanely modest for him yeah
yeah he apparently doesn't live in like
a mansion or anything he still just
living just a regular regular house and
then he bought another one and uh the
second one in 2020 for 260. dude yeah
what is salt of the earth
it doesn't seem like he's at home very
much
based on how crazy his videos are all
the time
so okay based on that so many how many
houses you think you bought he could
have bought a hundred houses for like 30
million he bought five and the remaining
three oh that's 1.5 1.45 combined
so he only bought five that's not that
bad that's not that crazy yeah he's
trying to get one more
there's just one house left on the Block
well it depends who's living there like
a bunch of like uh
is it like uh some kind of weird uh cult
where everybody there's like 100 people
in one house and they all like have I
don't think Euros I think it's just I
think it's just his like crew and
employees you know oh then people are
way overreacting about this
well there's kind of two levels to it
there's people that just think it's
culty to have all of your employees live
in a house in houses that you own which
okay fair I don't think he's making a
move there
right now
that would start to feel a little cold
it's like a classroom it's like it's
like a guest room he's like I got a
whole house you could right all right
and then the the other level of it is
people making comparisons to uh it being
like a company Town
um which you know is like historically
when companies would own the whole town
but I think a key distinction of a
company town is that they also own all
of the stores and your employees get
paid in coupons to the store yeah fun
bucks to the stores
um which obviously is not what he's
doing at least yet maybe uh maybe it'll
be feastables only uh in a couple years
but as of right now
Beast water yeah
um
I do think yeah I can see it being in a
ghost town that place is definitely
going to be abandoned someday
what the neighborhood Beast the Mr Beast
neighborhood hmm it's gonna be a ghost
town
I'm sure of it just sell it off right
Liz is just in a normal neighborhood
yeah it's like a residential block I
don't see a big deal here
the there remains just one hold out
house which Donaldson's former neighbor
attributed to the family likely wanting
their kids to finish school oh so he's
going door to door and just being like
sell me your house yeah why the [__]
don't they ask for more money from him
the article says that they did he bought
them over Market
like none of the ones that weren't on
the market he just like approached them
with a cash offer significantly over
what the market price would be and they
took it because why it says the
remaining three he paid 1.45 million
which is like half a million so that
seems like a lot more than the other
idiots got
dummies
you got Mr Beast trying to buy your
house you didn't hold out
I mean if they didn't like and
know the neighborhood and yeah their
kids go to school and don't want to
switch schools or whatever I could see
not wanting to do it oh yeah no I can
see not wanting to do it I'm just saying
the people that sold out Cheapo
the idea is to boost productivity that's
a little creepy
that that part of it is weird
that's like the Google thing where
they're like we have kitchen and gyms
and places you can sleep we don't want
you to leave yeah it's so comfortable
here it's amazing in fact you don't ever
even need to go home
they act like it's this good thing they
have world-class chefs cooking for us so
we don't ever have to leave right we can
keep working all the time
it is a weird position because if you if
you came in here and you were like okay
guys I want to do
two episodes a day from now on
um and I know that's a lot to ask but
listen
I bought the whole neighborhood and I
have a four bedroom house it's yours Dan
but we gotta do double the amount of
content
but he's not giving them the house he
owns the house they're just no no like
but it's a four bedroom house it's yours
to live in so you would consider that I
mean
I guess not it's just like that does
sound it's pretty gnarly like the
reality and but and obviously that's not
a one for one with I don't know what Mr
Beast is asking I mean it's not a bad
word it's not a bad analogy I'm sure
Ethan's like love is already living in
the backyard
but then the bull house
he's out there juicing
yeah I don't know
the Boost productivity thing is a little
creepy
you're right that does sound work is not
very Silicon Valley yeah it's like you
gotta
people need to have their life yeah
right you know right
but at this end of the day it's not that
big of a deal either
uh some people are in defensive
Mysteries while there's criticism even
compared him to a slave owner
um
a little far it's a little wage slave
owner
I mean it does create a weird that's you
know we were joking about it with love
earlier but it does create kind of weird
dynamic where your boss owns your house
and then if you [__] up or leave then
you lose your house yeah you don't just
lose your job you lose your house not
good yeah it's not a good situation I I
know when Mr Beast was in some kind of a
hot water before for firing someone he
said that he paid that employee for like
he said you you're going to be paid
forever like for the coming years even
though you're not working a severance of
huge Severance yeah yeah like an insane
Severance
um so I I I feel like he wouldn't just
kick them out you know no I don't but
it's a way it's a weird dynamic
definitely
maybe you want to leave and do something
else you're like [__] though got this
house yeah I guess that's not his
problem
if the conditions are so good people
don't want to leave
uh Mr Beast responded to a hate comment
on Twitter
he said
only I could get canceled for giving
people a place to live with no strings
attached
all these company Town tweets make no
sense I was just helping some people
yeah the company Town comparison is not
a great one because there was a lot more
to accompany Town than just providing
housing to employees
um
him saying provide a house with no
strings attached though I mean
well they have to work for him yeah
that's not really true right like there
are strings attached they might be
reasonable but
it's not like you just gave them a house
like if you gave them the house and gave
them the deed then yeah then obviously
that's extremely generous but
there's definitely a string there he
said uh this guy tweeted out this
actually got 90 000 likes uh when it was
screenshotted what a nice man surely a
CEO buying homes and creating
neighborhoods for their employees
families has no historical relevance or
background at all
right so they're referencing that
company Town thing and then he responded
only I could get cancer for giving
please play a place to live with no
strings attached but then again it's
like why do they need a house just pay
them just pay them well and they'll get
people can get their own [__] place
whenever they want
like what's the need what's the need
there the need shouldn't exist the the
need is like you said it's that we can
get so much more done if the whole team
lives on the same block and you know
milk in the morning no commute we can
just pop across the street have a
meeting you know what I mean so
you know there is a there is a benefit
to it
from his perspective
okay what's did air did uh
erdogan erdogan
did he win
last I saw uh he was ahead but not by
enough to avoid a runoff uh I don't know
what the latest is I
he's a [__] psychotic freako
see that it looks like there will be a
runoff
I just see it like trending big time
right now and I know the runoff was
already announced yesterday
is this guy capable of rigging elections
in Turkey because I know he's basically
uh I you know what we should talk to
Hassan about it because he knows a lot
more about it than I do yeah I should
all the feedback that I've seen is that
turkey is like
it's not super duper rigged but it's
like a little rigged okay which frankly
sounds like ours exactly so
yeah
okay well uh there it is uh Mr Beast
neighborhood
won't you be my won't you be my won't
you be my neighbor
here's Mr Beast in a month
going door to door
This Man shows up at your door what do
you do
we are doing a Lamborghini race
love it we love Mr Rogers we love it we
love mysteries
oh you guys this is a great update
weights and Fish Guy they went they got
sentenced to 10 Jason 10 days in jail
one day for each pound
that feels like
that feels like a fair punishment for
for the crime you know what I personally
feel that crime was more significant you
think it should go away
I think they should have gone away for
longer because again listen to this they
won 130 000 boat
by cheating
uh right
yeah
they got caught putting weights and fish
you guys all remember this iconic clip
mm-hmm
Ohio fishing tournament it was revealed
that the winning group had allegedly
stuffed their catches full of weights
they would have received almost 29
thousand dollars had they whatever
what is this clip what the [__] is this
clip
it's it seems to be a news story about
it
we got weights and [__]
um anyway so uh
both men pleaded guilty to a felony
felony cheating
damn that's awesome that that's a thing
wrung up felony cheating boys we got him
cheating
this ran had a card up his sleeve felony
cheating right
like I'm cheating right
uh Jacob and Chase were sentenced to ten
days in jail as well as their fishing
license suspended what does that mean
can you just get another fishing license
it's not like they're oh they're just
blacklisted dude no more fishing ain't
no more fishing around here what about
in a different state can I fish in
Louisiana
they're Bass Pro Shop membership's been
revoked all right damn
tragic
Ally bring them up this guy's the dude
this guy ruled I love him
[Applause]
it's not right what they did
it ain't right
it's a felony chain
free my boy dude I support them so
addition you support weights and support
the weights guys it's kind of he's based
[__] these fishermen
I guess my boy listen hello everybody
you know what fish we gotta free them
power to the felony cheaters
that guy who's all triggered pissed off
guarantees Trump voter
oh yeah yeah those guys are [__] them
those weights and fish balls are big
time Hillary spoilers no no no no no oh
no no
um
uh let's see in addition to jail
sentence and the forfeiture of the
prizes the men will be serving one and a
half years probation
are we subject to maximum fishing
license suspension what is the maximum
uh fishing license suspension in Ohio
specifically
that doesn't seem like that harsh of a
punishment I'm sorry
you ain't allowed to fish around here no
more
what happens if I do you get like a
twenty dollar ticket
so uh
you know
that's the end of that story that's big
news yep finally some resolution finally
Justice we've been waiting
waiting fish brother
I'll tell you there's nothing more
American than doing whatever it takes to
win
right exactly they're Heroes who cares I
put a couple weights in the fish
makes it fit I would have won anyway big
you see the size of this sucker
that seems like a total crap shoot by
the way how do you catch a bigger fish
than other people it's just totally
random
right uh I don't know enough about
fishing that's sport really if
there's probably I'm sure there's a
difference man hell no the way I jiggle
my hook is real real fancy well it's not
just about it you ever seen a real
fisherman jiggle his the bike the bite
is a luck but actually reeling it in is
pretty hard right like there probably is
they're not that big
I've reeled in a fish when I was a kid
okay
okay we need an H3 over here we got a
Fisher over here we should go group deep
sea fishing fishing competition love you
want to go deep sea fishing ever done
that hell yeah brother let's go yeah
yeah there's blue whales coming up hey
blue whale season's coming up
really there's a blue whale seal
something oh oh on oh yeah right off the
coast here there's blue whales uh
migrating through the through the
to the Pacific off the coastal Cali
that is cool blue bits are pretty cool
they're pretty cool uh let's see how
them toon Coons
oh this is interesting uh I don't know
does c-man
does he do you know if he is in hotel
management
because they hear what I mean I don't
know this one hotel manager in Nashville
charged with sucking on sleeping guest
toes oh no
T-man involved in this
I could see him being a manager I feel
like he was sort of like Forrest Gump he
did everything he's been everywhere yeah
well how else does he like Forrest Gump
she's had an exciting life he was in the
war he was in Vietnam like for us
[Music]
you never know what Forrest Gump is uh
Italian
that
may be true no life was like a box of
chocolates uh here's the photo of the
guy I feel like this dude and c-man
would get on really well though
this is the toe sucker
my man that's my boy
huh
that looks like a toe sucker to me the
alleged assault happened at 5am March
30th at Hilton you would expect at a
Hilton those are nice hotels a little
bit better service
police said David the night manager at
the hotel made a key card so we could
enter guest's room
how do you think you're going to get
away with that right by the way when I'm
at a hotel I always [__] dad
nobody's coming sucking my toes that's
right imagine waking up and seeing that
at the foot of your bed it's okay [__]
okay go back to go back to sleep
he made a key card so he could enter the
guest room the guest said he woke up to
find Neil sucking on his toes and
immediately confronted him
right I mean that's gonna wake you up
that's what I'm confused about like what
was the plan he couldn't resist he
probably peeped the toes [__] down his
leg sucks
and said I must have those toes in my
mouth at all costs good good point yeah
he probably came in there was gonna be
all stealthy just look but then he
couldn't like he's gonna help himself
I don't want to victim on them listen I
don't want a victim blame but this guy
probably walked in wearing flip-flops oh
he was his hands just like fresh and fit
said that he was asking for hot you know
what I mean perfect [__] little
piggies
okay now I'm not one to [__] shame but
he kind of if you didn't want your toes
suck you should have put on he should
have had yeah but on a [__] sock you
[__]
maybe two yeah
funnily enough that follows the same
logic yeah I wonder if he eyes them
during check-in and then that's cocky
yeah yeah that's how he picks
sting uh Neil admitted to the police he
had to enter the room but he claimed it
was because he smelled smoke oh those
toes are so hot this man I caught you
with my toe in your mouth he didn't
report the smoke to security and there
was no other reports about the smell huh
well I mean
maybe the hoe is on fire he's putting it
out yeah
right when officers asked Neil where the
key was he said he threw it away the key
was not found Neil was taken into
custody
at his home in Lebanon Tennessee
he's charged with aggravated burglary
and assault he's being held on 25 000
Bond
burglary what
aggravated burglary stole his heart his
foot virginity
he stole his foot virginity yeah
dude that was awesome story man that's
[__] now that's a story I like
and here is uh our boy
Neil from Nashville our friend my friend
Neil who bent over
when my friend Neil wait no I'm confused
it says Neil was taking a custody but
here it says his name was
maybe it's David Neil yeah it's David
Neal okay you got the wrong guy
this boy I'll let you suck my toes boy
[Music]
you want it so bad you can have it just
make sure I'm sleeping
oh
like a little Golem sneak it in there
like Smeagol crawling on the floor
my precious toe [__] up Hobbit
he's been corrupted by the toe ring
I wish I had more info it's a shame that
we have to move on from the story I just
want to keep dogs should get him to call
him
you know what let's Reach Out
let's reach out let's post his bail
yeah
maybe yeah we should pay his bond and
then get away man I know 25 000 for that
guy hell no I'd rather buy like 10
gatsbys
s
all right
I found out this guy shot his roommate
in 1996. the toe sucker sorry not
somebody yeah what and uh Neil I gotta
get him Neil had a lengthy rap sheet
that included voluntary manslaughter
wait he killed him yeah [__] holy [__]
oh my God this man killed someone and
he's working the front desk
so died
oh no oh no room service
[__] funny
oh [__] me imagine waking up and
thinking it's a sleep paralysis demon
also and then it's the manager from
downstairs
this man killed his roommate voluntary
manslaughter for shooting his roommate
during a fight in 1996.
holy [__]
what a cool dude
[Music]
foreign
Five Nights at Freddy's Five Nights at
uh the Hilton
Neil
friend Neil
my friend Neil Brennan reportedly
suffered post-traumatic stress and
struggled to get to sleep in the wake of
the alleged toe sucking incident oh no
all right Brennan I'm not I'm trying to
feel bad for you but let me see your
feet
right
just how just how hot are those little
little let me see security footage I
wonder if he was pleasuring himself when
he was doing it or if it was like a
hands-free e-jack or you know a lot a
lot of ins and outs a lot of questions
yeah based on what I understand from
talking to c-man he probably wasn't
jerking it he was probably fully focused
it was more like savor it save it for
the uh
the masturbation later yeah yeah that's
probably yeah because he didn't get like
an indecent exposure charge too right it
was just the burglary and what was the
other one uh assault assault
so like theoretically how does this work
so he Creeps in at night lifts the cover
back away from the toes or does he creep
under the covers
or the guy could have been having one
leg out one under well that would have
been fortunate for him but like I can't
assume that like a half Jesus you know
right he was coming in there just to
look and then those feet were laying in
the open and he just you know it's like
a golden like a golden treasure chest or
this guy could be completely innocent
there there was Smoke there was a fire
and put it out with his mouth he put it
out with his mouth the little the little
fire on this guy's phone he's a hero
yeah we should be celebrating and then
shredded the key that he used for some
reason well no that got that went up in
flames in the fire you know he said he
threw it away oh okay what's the name of
that what's the name of that attorney
representing Stephen Avery
Kathleen something she like I don't know
she does like she takes up these
impossible cases
Kathleen Zellner yes Kathleen Zellner is
about to represent the tell sucker
Johnny if you can find a way
she's gonna find like forensic dust in
the corner that shows some combustion
took place right
and suck
so that's that's a great story man that
was good
um
we got more
he's got some images of him this is him
that's him my man here's the full
picture this dude killed someone
yo this dude killed somebody
wait is this younger one that's from his
93 that was for the manslaughter yeah
oh he's he don't even feel bad about
this at all
there's a throwback Thursday
this dude killed somebody
and this this man grew up he was totally
well adjusted just relax just want to
suck on your teeth covered you know
some say he would he was rehabilitated
in prison rehabilitated
[Music]
I'm also reading that when the victim
reported it to hotel security they
didn't take him serious so he had to
call the police
that's gotta hurt
who's gonna believe that I woke up and
this [__] was sucking my toes
that does seems far-fetched it does seem
a little wild
it's like something like out of some
Bizarro shining spin-off very good Mr
Torrance
um how long we've been going three hours
ish yo so we got the prices uh obviously
we'll talk more about it but in case you
guys are curious where was it Sam did
you send in the Discord she did here
I'll send it again oh thank you
for Sam
oh so
there's a crazy story about Mayo for Sam
that someone in the comments pointed out
Ian was eating mayonnaise on the show
as a as a compromise to avoid talking
about Sam
you remember this
it was literally mail for Sam
um
like literally interesting
am I right Ian that happened
yeah yeah that uh
I have my contract somewhere that I
right we even signed a contract and
everything right mail for Sam
[Applause]
so I'm gonna need you to stop talking
about it uh it's still still yeah that
works for me
yeah but you weren't supposed to talk
about it what was the terms if break he
broke the contract
technicality hearing oh it was to talk
about the uh Bachelor uh
segment anymore
right because he went rogue here's the
here's the comment Ian eating the mail
in that one episode was because he
didn't want to talk about Sam aka the
wild card at that time so it's full
circle because it was literally male for
Sam
he downed that male for saying oh
excellent observation Gabby can I can I
say something and
uh oh no button are we no I know it's
not just usually can I say something is
I get a little tense no no it's not that
it's not that kind of say something
can we do another episode season of The
Bachelor but it worked out so good like
look at Ian and Sam
[Music]
didn't work out so good in the case of
my uh right and brother-in-law and that
you just said it yourself they went
rogue you don't remember how upset you
are about all that at the time well it
was good content but I'm happy with the
results I mean Sam is wonderful I mean
look she wouldn't even be in our lives
but Sam wasn't like a contestant on that
I know but it brought her to his DMS
right
well
because I dm'd him about something else
but then I was like oh I should have
applied for The Bachelor because you put
it we put out in the world that that Ian
was single and ready to mingle right yes
so so you you know
I think it's safe to say it would not
have happened
without my intervention
and why I'll be the the best man when
you guys uh
so true get married ring bearer
Godfather
we'll see we'll see Godfather Two Kids
commit commit right now on the day of
your child's birth the day I become The
Godfather that I always meant to be
this child is my godson
I will look after him I will teach him
the ways
[Music]
that's a fair point that you make again
there's others too
um also I was trying to find the clip
but I can't but there is a clip of you
emphatically yelling about how the
bachelor is over never again right I
wanted to throw that in your face but
well I was thinking that because every I
was thinking that maybe it'd be a fun
way to and to bring love in
[Music]
a bachelor with love and that's of
course up to love right I gotta pass I'm
way too socially awkward to do anything
like that on the show
think about it think about it I'll think
about it yeah think about it
you know
no no I mean listen every time we've
done it it resulted in May well not
sorry not marriage but love love
and your name is Love
that's what that means
no such thing as a coincidence
knowing knowing the way I'm hyping it
whoever wins probably gonna kill you or
something
yeah it is possible two two loves and
one death
[Music]
pretty good odds pretty good pretty good
all right so here's the prices you guys
and tell me if you think this is crazy I
think it is
t-shirts 20 bucks
that's insane that's like cheaper than
most people's merch yeah that's true
and that's like beautiful designer
luxury okay you're gonna love these
t-shirts are you crazy are you out of
your mind uh this sweatshirt here is 55
dollars
hoodie sixty dollars hats and beanies
twenty dollars
three pair of socks I think it's a three
pair for 25. is that right
it's a three pair
short
sweatpants 55 is that good
I hope you guys think so I I swear to
god dude we squeezed it
zip up is I think also 60.
yeah the zip up Hoodie
and the hoodie are 60
the socks are so nice you guys great
prices okay I'm telling you why so cheap
just because we this is my special
project
as prices go up I says no our prices go
down oh you wouldn't expect it but we we
want the people we are of them they say
use that exactly it's like don't let him
see somebody's like Ethan no we're
losing tons of money we need to raise
the prices no no lower them that's kind
of what happened dude
and so all of our best people is a
powerful business mind
no no no no no all of the greatest Minds
we came together and we said help and I
said listen here's where we start
I'm talking
a sweatshirt for 50 bucks 55 is where we
got they're like it can't be done
it says it cannot be done
I said we're gonna make it happen so we
go to the drawing board we look at our
current
uh our current kind of template for the
sweatshirt look at the fabric the weight
of the fabric
all the kind of pieces and stuff that
make it
more expensive every little thing makes
it more expensive you know
paired it all down it's but it's still
so nice like you can see the fabric is
just gorgeous gorgeous the colors are
amazing
and again we just crushed the margin
you know um
so that's I'm I'm very excited I'm very
excited
[Applause]
uh thank you
someone says my teddy fresh hoodie is
better than my quality for my Essential
ones I I these these ones are top dude
I'm telling you they're so nice
that's what it is
Classics is what we're calling it
beautiful stay there
congratulations thank you
uh pathetic loser Tucker Carlson posted
this video announcing he'll be doing a
show on Twitter now dude of course Elon
Musk teamed up with Tucker Carlson
how much do you think he had to pay him
I mean that dude was making like 60
million a year at [__] sucker I hope
he's not paying him oh he is you know he
is it'd be awesome if he wasn't
why would he do it because he could go
work somewhere else and make a [__] no I
don't think he can
he has a non-compete
so he can't be on another Network
oh interesting
can you could have gone and done like
rumble or like some [__] like that
though you wanna how [__] insane our
world is
almost a million likes on this video 130
million views
this goofy doughy racist little [__]
people actually care what he says it's
astonishing
for Carlson you often hear people say
the news is full of lies but most of the
time you guys just got fired by the way
stop with that chipper hi I'm no you got
fired okay taka shut the [__] hey it's
Tucker Carlson you often hear people say
the news is full of lies but most of the
time that's not exactly right much of
what you see on television or read the
New York Times is in fact true in the
literal sense it could pass one of the
media's own fact checks lawyers would be
willing to sign off on it it's been it
says nothing it's literally nothing they
may have but that doesn't make it true
it's not true at the most basic level
the news you consume is a lie [__]
you heard the news
the most popular newsmen in the world or
no in the country
I don't think it was just on cable news
he has the number one show on cable news
oh I think like nightly new ABC Nightly
News or whatever and then Tucker Carlson
show I like how he goes I'm not part of
the media
shout out to David Muir on ABC for two
days guys they're the bad guys the place
I was two days ago they're the bad guy
all right wealthiest and most Insidious
kind facts have been withheld on purpose
along with proportion and perspective
you are being manipulated how does that
work let's see if I tell you that a man
has been unjustly arrested for armed
robbery that is not strictly speaking a
lie he may have been framed at this
point there's been no trial so no one
can really say
but if I don't mention the fact that the
same thing has been arrested
due to his Cadence is crazy like the way
he's just delivering this
he's really got that nailed in that oh
hey if I did this
you're being lied to
[__] Gobles for the same crime six
times before am I really informing you
no I'm not I'm misleading you and that's
what the news media are doing in every
story that matters he's a little racist
dog whistle there his whole example
makes no [__] sense he's like he said
if I tell you this guy got arrested
unjustly
yeah because maybe he was framed or
something but it would still be a lie
it's like
well there'd be no Mission or not even
but so he says but he's been arrested
five other times he's doing this thing
where it's like okay yeah you killed the
protester but did you know that that
protester committed a crime right he
didn't know that when he killed him
[__]
CCO
every day of the week every week of the
year are they're doing that about the
the homeless guy that got murdered
and the subway we never talked about
that we have not talked about that now
but yeah there's a lot of that going on
then now people are digging up his whole
life story trying to prove that he's a
bad guy
right which maybe he was but also you
he's probably still didn't deserve to
get murdered for no reason
even even if it was like a death
sentence right
a semi-checked
what's it like to work in a system like
that after more than 30 years in the
middle of it we could tell you stories I
was there two days ago and forcibly
removed
but I'm telling you that's all part of
the system that we all hate
they were paying me 60 million dollars
and they give me a fat severance
best you can hope for in the news
business at this point is the freedom to
tell the fullest truth that you can but
they're always and here's my fullest
truth the bell curve is correct
I want to reinstate the clan
and white men would never fight like
that
to limit and you know that if you bump
up against those limits often enough you
will be fired for it that's not a guess
it's guaranteed every person who works
in English language media understands
that the rule of what you can't say
defines everything it's filthy really
and it's utterly I have not been able to
say the n-word on air for 30 years that
is censorship at its most quintessential
I want to be able to say the n-word
and all other racial slurs
it's a violation of my free speech
then he pulls out like a white clan hood
and I'm putting and now I'm becoming Who
I Really Am
takes out a burning cross
now I can finally speak my mind
and a noose in the other hand
because we're crazier and crazy you
can't have a free Society if people
aren't allowed to say what they think is
true speech is the fundamental
prerequisite for democracy that's why
it's enshrined in the first of our
constitutional amendments amazingly as
of tonight well done dude holy [__]
that's what I'm saying who like his
audience watched this
who cares they got like the million
times there aren't many platforms left
that allow Free Speech the last big one
remaining in the world the only one is
Twitter where we've gotta [__] love
that man
Twitter
it's the last place for free speech
unless you're Ethan Klein making fun of
its owner
unless you goof on the owner it's the
last great place for free speech
unless you're the opposition party in
the Turkish election right
you know what's funny or not funny but
real interesting
um
Twitter has been complying with
government requests to remove content
like 95 of the time before Elon it was
like 50 percent yeah Twitter though
Twitter actually did push back on a lot
of takedown requests so just by
comparison he's way worse for free
speech yeah we are now
Twitter on Twitter I can post tits and
nobody will say anything you can post
porn on Twitter
I could for example tweet out a picture
of hunger ff's giant prolapse dildo
which I did do by the way it is on
Twitter right now oh you guys I forgot
to talk about that hunger sent us his
prolapse uh
-huh dildo
sure did you guys can see it on Twitter
it's pretty wild there's two sizes too
the small one's really big
Pole
it has long served as the place where
our national conversation incubates and
develops Twitter is not a partisan site
everybody's allowed here for all the
owner literally like
he's such a loser don't even need to say
it no
also he posted this like a week ago and
nothing since like get your [__]
together dude I thought you were this
video is the caption was like I'm back
or something I was like God you just put
a two minute video in where you [__]
about Free Speech together and dipped
again
and we think that's a hunger is calling
in on Wednesday to discuss his uh
Triumph
[Music]
in the in the space
people are saying so some people are
freaking out about the prolapse on
Twitter so apparently he wasn't able to
dip his prolapse into like Silicon which
is how you usually
make something like that but they did a
whole ass
like 3D digital scan of the prolapse you
know like bullet time kind of [__]
so
cool
oh somebody said of the prolapse
so this is why you were late Ethan had
to go to town before a stream
also somebody said Zach do it for the
show
do what stick it up my ass yes
and lubricate it with mayonnaise if you
would please oh tasty awful I'll let you
know after the finger in my ass we'll
see where we go okay okay fair enough a
good thing
and yet for the most part the news that
you see analyzed on Twitter comes from
media organizations that are themselves
thinly disguised propaganda Outlets you
see it on cable news you talk about it
on Twitter
the result may feel like a debate but
actually The Gatekeepers are still in
charge
we think that's a bad system we know
exactly how it works sick of it because
we starting soon we'll be bringing a new
version of the show we've been doing for
the last six and a half years to Twitter
we bring some other things too which
we'll tell you about but for now we're
just grateful to be here bro
he's gonna have a show on Twitter man if
he has a show on Twitter then I'm the
[__] Pope it's not happening also
I don't know about you guys maybe it's
an Android thing but the video player on
Twitter is like totally broken now like
half the times I open a video I won't
[__] play anything well it's good
everybody works freezes halfway through
and it's glitchy as [__] yeah so good
luck good luck bud
uh wishing you all the best my friend
Tucker Carlson last great American
Taka Taka Taka Taka this guy's such a
[__] loser
uh yeah so there it is um I guess that's
about it
that's about it anything else nah
that's a good dad oh I wanna go play
some Zelda oh I wanted to ask you guys
how how far have you guys gotten uh this
guy is the still in the Newbie Zone
apparently so I'm a little disappointed
maybe you're talking about bringing your
switch everywhere but you're not playing
I mean I played it myself and uh and
then I wanted to play it on Stream So I
restarted it so oh okay yeah
so I'm just in like the fourth uh Shrine
okay so you're almost done with the
Newbie area yeah
it's pretty fun actually the starting
area wasn't it's kind of dope yeah the
controls were annoying me a little bit
but I'm getting more used to it the
graphics looked crazy bad when I was up
there I don't know if it's the lighting
of the game up there but once you go
down to Hyrule it's I don't know I don't
have a problem anymore okay I'm excited
to get out of the Newbie area oh you're
still there too yeah you're playing but
you've never played right
I've played some of the others okay yeah
so I know kind of what to expect because
I saw you complaining about
so you were having a problem with the
game weren't you
um I just I was just in this like hole
and I couldn't you're stuck in a hole
well there was evidently a sword oh
right I couldn't behind it oh you're
talking about the cave Ian sent a video
and she was she was stuck in the
starting room didn't realize she needed
to pick the sword up off the ground
that's bad that that builds badly I
spent about 10 minutes in there
how far are you Dan I am decently far
have you done the the first big Temple
yet do you know what I'm talking about
like the first like big dungeon uh I
guess not no I haven't I've just been
like I've been enjoying I'm just I won't
say anything it was that was one of my
biggest complaints about the last game
is that the the dungeons the dungeons
you remember they were like the big like
walking things which was cool and it
always had that component of like you
have to get on it but they were all like
kind of the same thing and there wasn't
that many of them
at least the first like Temple the
experience of all Nick was so good and
your boss was awesome I know what you're
talking about because I have the quest
okay but every time I go try to do it I
get so distracted sidetracked yeah I
find like a settlement or uh or a cave
or a temple the cave systems is awesome
yeah you've been exploring a lot of
caves
uh you're talking about the big the big
cave no there's like tons of caves yeah
I mean like there's just regular have
you gone down yet though
uh no I haven't done it I guess I
haven't done any of that oh you gotta go
down I know that there's a underworld I
know that based on what like the whole
Overworld again that's what I figured so
[__] big this game is massive there's
like a Sky Map yep there's a surface map
which is as big as the first game yep
and then there's an underworld map it's
crazy it's I'm gonna be playing this
game for a long [__] time it's so fun
it's so fun it's cool how there's
different ways to beat different you
know levels like I'm so used to Zelda
there's one set way of beating a puzzle
but in this one there's so many
different ways to beat that that's what
makes it so good it's like there's
nothing like it and everything is so
intuitive like there's just been so many
times that would be like in any other
game you would assume that the game is
somehow gonna have an invisible wall or
something to keep you on the rail
there's nothing nothing it's just like
whatever you can think of a way to solve
this you can do it and then with all the
engines and [__] it's gonna get so crazy
but for me I always pump my stamina
because when you have tons of stamina
you can the world is your voice I
started doing the the hearts at first
and then I remembered and I was like I
don't I need to get mine I went I think
I went like five stamina and then start
got a couple hours but it's all about
the stamina dude
here's Sam in the starting area
oh we have the video yeah I got the vid
got the receipts
don't claim me Nintendo all right get
out of this room
oh my god of course Sam the tutorial's
over now dude the tutorials kicking your
ass
whenever you're ready
do a cocoon
yeah
just whenever you're ready just head out
of the room
right there right there standing on the
sword wait where was it
yeah oh it said examine yep there it is
right there
I have no sword I'm naked or Sam
you hit it she figures it out oh you do
you got to give the happy resolution
[__] I can't slide how about you pick up
the sword on the ground
I've been there we did it in there sword
was not there sometimes you get stuck on
the silly stuff you know well it was so
dark I was trying to climb out I was
climbing up the wall in that cave for
like 10 minutes
I thought that was the way
can I ask you a question were you high
at the time no oh okay she isn't you
don't smoke you don't [__] with that
only Sonic Sonic Rune dude that yeah the
incident
um
Yeah the more I play it the more I like
it and there's a ton of stamina checks
Dan so
for sure yeah okay here's a pump in the
stand I'm gonna do a little thing
when I I pumped my stamina so I could
Glide to the floating Castle have you
done that yet
the main like Hyrule castle Yeah other
giant ones no Hyrule Castle uh the story
took me there at one point but no I
haven't like thoroughly climbed to the
top and there's insane [__] loot oh
like end game loot oh that makes sense
I'm fully stacked yeah last night I was
uh I was trying to unlock all the maps
so I was just like running around I was
yeah because I finished that first
temple and I figured now I want to just
explore for a while so
yeah I think I've only got like two of
the platforms so I just I've really been
putting around you know
I try to get Lena into Zelda so many
times and never works out it ends up me
just like screaming press [__] hey
hey I thought it was pretty
good she's new through it okay yeah it's
tough it is tough you know
but there it is
that right [__] love it
nah I haven't started it yet
oh so Sam is just yeah I like watching
uh Sam try to play it
but I haven't tried that I've never
played many Zelda games oh okay
yeah it's nice to watch I like watching
Nintendo games like other people play
them it's very Zen I'm very cheap it is
a very Zen the game is very beautiful
yeah
um it's amazing though because you look
back at the first game and a lot of
people say
this just feels like uh an expansion
pack not a new game
but so what they took this vast world
populate it with all kinds of cool [__]
and then they added way more
so you have the first game the like the
scale of the first game and then like
doubled yeah and then just kind of like
built Minecraft into the game on top of
everything I love the building aspects
yeah it's crazy it's so fun it's so
satisfying like when you I've killed a
few mini bosses that drop like special
items that you confuse to your weapons
right yeah like I killed this uh
this one of these big rock bosses in a
cave that had like glowing rocks
and he dropped this big ass glowing rock
that I attached to the weapon it's like
[__] sick it's crazy how they're able
to like change that series with every
game and like innovate it in an
interesting way it really is impressive
absolutely because it's the same story
every that damn time yeah
yeah gotta fix that sword every [__]
game when I saw him walking with with
Zelda in the cave at the very beginning
I was like she's about to [__] get
kidnapped called it there's no chance
she's not kidnapped right now
they made link shorter in this one he's
a Shortcake I'd have noticed that my
toxic masculinity doesn't like it
um he's Nimble he's a rock climber you
know you got to keep it light
tell you what
gotta keep it light bar
you turn in those
codoroco seeds
sure have you seen all of the videos of
people becoming obsessed with torturing
those guys don't wait no various ways oh
we're seeing this stuff I want to watch
those I'll send it to you after the show
I forget where I saw it but yeah there's
like these little these cute little yeah
Leaf guys and and they're wearing a big
backpack and he can't even walk and he
needs help yeah they're like very cute
and innocent and so of course because
you can build [__] in this game they're
just like these torture device where
it's just like blasting it with [__]
flamethrowers from like 20 directions
as much like pain as they can inflict on
them as well very funny you know I was
just thinking it was just an idea I'm
just thrown out there but you know we
love the the Powerpoints from Olivia the
drama ones I was thinking it'd be funny
if we did like a [__] nerdy one about
like Zelda or some [__] like that I
don't know if people will be into that
no there's my passion I want Olivia to
do the nerdy one that's right it would
be funny make Olivia play Zelda for a
weekly Zelda
let's talk about the drama yeah let's
talk about the drama that exists in the
in this relationships it's hundreds of
years of tea it's a lot thousands bro
thousands right thousands yeah okay she
went back like what like yeah could you
please explain
right the princess
wait she's a princess I want to make
sure you cover the the three brands
alternative timelines as well yeah if
you could make sure of course
it's pretty dense
but I'll tell you what the way that the
gliding works when you launch up is so
much fun it's so fun it sounds boring
but it is I like that you guys like it
obviously it is so fun
because I was wondering how they gonna
prove the towers where you could jump
off and fly wherever this is better
right yeah definitely and if you have a
ton of stamina you can literally like
fly
forever
you know I really like it's kind of
stupid but when you jump in water and it
splashes like that and it hits the
camera it's very satisfying so I didn't
even notice the sound design and all
that
I'm at the uh Wendy Bird City to do that
part of the quest okay so you're you'll
do the temple that I was talking about
tonight most likely I just decided that
okay I'm gonna do a quest now
it's worth it's worth doing I've crushed
a lot of temples
Zelda is a girl
so I'm saying you need a PowerPoint
Zelda's the Princess link is the warrior
who's always trying to save Zelda
whereas the Mario kobecat
are there like activities to do so many
activities
you can glide there's mini games
probably
I just got to a whole town
that uh that is the um
the fashion center of the world oh my
gosh yeah and uh and there's a esteemed
designer like the uh the Chanel of this
world or whatever and she's sending me
on a whole Quest oh my gosh yeah I'm
telling you Gucci
yeah I think this is going to take me
months to beat this game because I just
um I love it
all right well that's it guys
uh that's it have a great evening thank
you everybody it's been such a fun time
being here on this wonderful Monday now
evening
uh members
join me tomorrow
for a members only live stream
featuring yours truly
who knows maybe you guys will learn
English number tomorrow
drill you never know you never know what
numbers
and uh remember members get to watch
are
crew reaction to the Zach lore video
so and remember Ian lore Enthusiast
please post your Clips I've seen a lot
of good ones popping up on the subreddit
for our next floor videos yep anyway
guys have a great night we'll see
everybody else on Wednesday for our
regular uh episode love you guys love
you guys love you guys
right
[Music]